[musique]
Donc Red Monnaie, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Nous vous recevons
dans le cadre de votre activité de
producteur, réalisateur, de
documentaires et plus spécialement sur
un documentaire que vous avez réalisé
sur l'anarchie.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Oh ben là, vous l'avez
fait hein. Je suis producteur,
réalisateur euh aussi musicien. J'ai un
groupe de rock électro qui s'appelle
Acab et euh et effectivement euh bon ben
je fais des documentaires de la musique
et je produis aussi les documentaires
d'autres réalisateurs.
Vous êtes fils de
de quelqu'un qui a créé le monde
diplomatique ?
Non, il l'a pas créé. Donc mon père euh
a dirigé le monde diplomatique mais
c'est euh c'est il a été créé par Hubert
Bmy, je crois et ensuite vraiment il a
pris son envol avec Claude Julien.
Combien ça coûte un documentaire à
500000 € ?
Alors ça dépend le coût moyen d'un
documentaire c'est 150000 €. Euh un
documentaire comme les documentaires sur
l'histoire de l'anarchisme c'est
beaucoup plus. Ils sont entre 3 et
400000 € par épisode. Voilà.
4 ans de boulot, 5 ans.
Ouais. Et qui sont pas terminés.
Un troisème épisode peut-être, mais on
en reparlera peut-être après.
Ouais.
Vous payez correctement vos salariés.
Parce que vous prenez des valeurs
anarchiques.
Oui. Alors euh d'abord, c'est pas parce
que j'ai fait un documentaire sur
l'anarchisme que je suis anarchiste.
J'ai aussi fait un documentaire avec mon
frère sur les abattoirs de port. Je ne
suis pas un seigneur dans les abattoirs
de porc.
10 ans 10 ans avant elle.
Ouais. Et euh Oui. Oui. Que s'appelle
euh euh Marche funèbre. C'est un petit
documentaire. Euh et mais effectivement
en revanche, on respecte entièrement le
le code du travail dans le cadre de
notre de notre société et puis on on
essaie même de de d'harmoniser les
salaires au sein de la société. Oui.
Vous êtes anarchique ? anarchiste,
on serait plutôt anarchique
qu'anarchiste, hein. C'est un peu
difficile. C'est un peu le thème de
l'émission, c'est-à-dire que c'est
difficile d'être dans une société dans
un système qui est un système
capitaliste et de fonctionner de manière
anarchiste,
surtout dans le cadre de l'audiovisuel
qui est soumis à tout un ensemble de
réglementations euh
légales qui font que ben on doit
respecter ces ces règles là pour pour
pouvoir faire les films. C'est quoi
votre constat sur la société actuelle ?
C'est une question très large.
Bon, la la société comme elle va là tout
particulièrement en ce moment, c'est un
constat àablanc. J'ai le sentiment, j'ai
fait un film sur Patrick Buisson avec
Vanessa Schneeder et Arian Chemin
où on on essayait de raconter derrière
la trajectoire de la personne, on
essayait de montrer cette reconquête des
esprits par l'extrême droite. Je crois
qu'on est arrivé au fait de ce de ce
mouvement-là d'hégémonie euh culturelle
de la part de l'extrême droite.
Et donc c'est une période qui est qui
est très sombre. En même temps, moi j'ai
une légère tendance à à des une forme
d'optimisme et à une j'ai une croyance
dans les phénomènes de cycle. Donc je
pense que à partir du moment où on est
en train d'arriver à un pic de la
domination de la pensée de droite voire
d'extrême droite, et bien en ce moment
on voit dans les jeunes générations
d'autres pensées émerger et qui vont
petit à petit sans doute reprendre
reprendre de l'influence.
Pourquoi vous dites qu'il y a il y a un
pic d'hégémonie de de pensée d'extrême
droite alors que à la louche 90 % des
journalistes sont de gauche ? 90 % des
journalistes détiennent les les le
stylo.
Pourquoi pourquoi dire qu'on est dans
une hégémonie d'extrême droite ?
Bon, c'est c'est un c'est un travail qui
a été fait par des grands sociologues
hein. L'analyse des
lesquels
bah notamment Bourdieu euh
Pierre Paix à son âme.
Ouais. euh l'analyse bon ben des
phénomènes de de structure.
Alors, je suis pas un spécialiste de
bourdieux, mais c'est pas parce que la
masse à l'intérieur d'une structure
pense d'une certaine façon que disons
l'inertie et la force de la structure
va
représenter la pensée de cette ce nombre
dominant. Et euh et on voit en revanche
à l'inverse que si sans doute la masse
des journalistes sont de gauche et
encore il faudrait réussir à définir là
ce qu'est la gauche et euh et vu que moi
la gauche s'arrête bien avant le Parti
socialiste.
Et donc il faudrait il faudrait voir en
revanche le nombre d'éditorialistes
de de directeurs de journaux et
évidemment d'actionnaires derrière qui
eux en revanche ne sont pas du tout de
gauche et pour certains sont maintenant
tiennent des propos d'une extrême droit
totalement décomplexée.
Alors il y a un jeu de mots sur votre
groupe.
Ouais.
OK. entre Akab de Mobidic et Acab de
Hops Bastard.
Ouais.
Est-ce que tous les flics sont des
bâtard ?
Bon, nous on a pris comme nom de groupe,
on a pris à Cab le nom du capitaine du
POD dans Mobidic qui nous semble être à
la fois une figure un peu prométéenne du
Dané et aussi en quelque sorte celui qui
défie à travers la la baleine blanche
Dieu mais aussi les éléments. Euh
c'est sur la la question de la police.
la police a un
une un rôle, une fonction
qui dépasse là aussi les individus. Donc
le slogan copser bastard est un slogan
qui révèle quelque chose de plus de plus
large et qui est une fonction de
maintien d'un ordre établi et qui est
l'ordre bourgeois. Donc à ce titre, la
la police est euh euh s'oppose à la
justice sociale euh et euh et euh et euh
aide à imposer toutes les formes de
domination ou à soutenir ou à encadrer
les formes de domination. Oui.
C'est quoi la justice sociale ?
C'est des questions à chaque fois assez
large. Euh
on vous laisse vous engouffrer puis
après on ira
Oui, c'est ça. Et après après on prend
les choses les unes les unes après les
autres.
Euh
bon, la justice sociale, c'est non
seulement l'égalité en droit, mais sans
doute une forme d'égalité en fait.
Voilà.
C'est quoi l'égalité en fait ?
Non, mais c'est j'ai l'impression de
remonter et d'être avec ma fille. Cela
dit, c'est un c'est un exercice qui est
pédagogique,
qui est non, qui Ouais. qui est
intéressant, même philosophique, je
pense.
Est-ce que votre pensée est suffisamment
costaud pour pouvoir être propagé ? Non,
je suis pas sûr hein. C'est pour ça je
suis pas sûr. C'est je suis pas J'ai
fait des études de philosophie mais je
ne suis pas philosophe. Je fais des
documentaires d'histoire mais je ne suis
pas historien.
Pourquoi tomber dans le misérabilisme de
l'impuissance ? en en disant ça
euh
Non mais c'est pas c'est pas être c'est
pas dire son impuissance que de dire ça
c'est dire plutôt ses limites. Je pense
que c'est intéressant de dire ses
limites. Euh et euh d'autant plus que
ce sont pas euh c'est pas exactement les
mêmes les mêmes exercices. Je pense là
par exemple
souvent on peut m'interroger comme
historien historien de l'anarchisme. Or
en réalité, moi j'ai fait un
documentaire sur l'histoire de
l'anarchisme en interviewant des vrais
historiens de l'anarchisme Gaitano
Manfredonia, Frank Minz,
Marian Enkel et cetera qui sont des des
des des mines et des puits de savoir sur
l'anarchisme.
Le travail de documentariste, même de
documentariste d'histoire, c'est un
travail qui est un petit peu différent
puisque ça demande ça ne demande pas de
de de connaître les dates par cœur, de
savoir tous les faits puisque j'ai tout
le temps dans ma salle de montage
d'abord c'est un travail d'équipe avec
une documentaliste, avec donc Marie
Baudouin, avec un menteur Basil Carré,
avec des conseillers historiques, ce que
j'ai cité, de reprendre les les
événements, les éléments de les de les
de les vérifier, de croiser les propos,
de chercher les images d'archives qui
peuvent aller avec, d'écarter un récit
ou une partie de l'histoire parce que je
n'ai aucune image d'archive à mettre
avec et alors que je trouve qu'elle est
très intéressante, ben je ne peux rien
mettre en face et donc réussir à
construire une séquence dessus ou à
l'inverse avoir une manière de raconter
un moment de l'histoire qui est très
forte et qui fait que on va devoir se
démener pour essayer de trouver les
images. pour accompagner ce moment de
l'histoire euh ce moment d'histoire dans
le film. Tout ça pour dire que euh c'est
pas la bande son
hein.
Oubliez pas la bande son l'ingénieur du
son.
Ouais. Ouais. bien sûr, le son, la
musique, c'est tout un travail c'est un
travail assez global mais qui un travail
qui se fait avec du temps, qui se fait
retirer du monde, qui n'est absolument
pas spontané
et et qui et qui permet ben de de de se
tromper 10 fois, de recommencer et
cetera. Donc c'est vraiment un exercice
qui est totalement différent de celui de
parler en direct euh devant des gens et
avec l'idée en plus que euh cette
parole, elle serait euh amenée à rester
et à être définitive quoi en quelque
sorte. C'est-à-dire que là, ça va être
sur internet et donc dans 2 ans, on on
pourra euh revoir que à tel moment il a
dit ça et cetera. Voilà. Donc c'est
c'est en général je me trouve plutôt
dans ta situation que dans la mienne.
Relaxe, tout va bien se passer. OK. Bon,
revenons au documentaires.
Euh,
c'est chaud quand même de t'interviewer.
Pourquoi ? parce que tu es tu fais des
documentaires, ton documentaire sur
l'anarchisme était vraiment bien foutu.
Euh plein de plein de ressources
historiques, plein de plein de dates,
plein de remise en situation, euh plein
de contextualisation,
tout ce qu'on aime. Donc c'est c'est
c'est très dur de t'interviewer. Euh euh
on va partir sur l'anarchisme comme ça.
Est-ce que l'anarchie a déjà perdu ou
est-ce que l'anarchie va revenir en
force ? Alors, selon ton point de vue,
alors euh c'est euh
en fait en fait derrière cette question,
il y en a plein d'autres mais euh euh
d'abord euh anarchie et anarchisme. Euh
disons que moi j'ai effectué une
distinction qui n'est pas forcément euh
que Gaitano Manfredonia ne fait pas
forcément. Euh par exemple, il il pour
lui l'anarchie et l'anarchisme c'est la
même chose.
Disons que moi, j'ai préféré considérer
l'anarchisme comme un courant de pensée
dont
la naissance
se fait avec Proudon qui se déclare
anarchiste au milieu du 19e siècle et
disons se se consolide ou apparaît
clairement comme un des courants du
socialisme
avec Bakounin. Et donc là aussi, c'est
pas la social, c'est le socialisme,
hein. Et donc l'anarchisme, c'est un
courant de pensée qui a tout un ensemble
de penseurs et qui a développé
ou a théorisé et mis en pratique tout un
ensemble d'idées et donc de pratique.
Euh l'anarchisme, il a pu avoir être
vaincu à des moments de l'histoire et
régresser. Il a aussi connu de très
forts moments d'expansion comme c'est
raconté dans le film euh à la fin du 19e
début du 20e siècle. On a un un
anarchisme, un mouvement anarchiste qui
est très fort, qui s'est exprimé à
travers la propagande par le fait. Donc
en en développant à l'échelle à
l'échelle mondiale la stratégie de
l'attentat par exemple qui est disons ça
son existence la plus spectaculaire,
celle dont on se souvient, dont toute
personne qui est allée au collège a des
souvenirs de ses attentats anarchistes
de la fin du 19e siècle, Ravachol,
Émil Henri, mais aussi enfin dans dans
tout le monde jusqu'en Amérique latine.
Mais derrière ça, il y a il y a d'autres
mouvements, d'autres courants de
l'anarchisme
qui sont l'anarchisme individualiste
ou l'anarcosyndicalisme par exemple qui
eux se sont finalement développés de
manière plus ont diffusé beaucoup plus
leurs idées sans forcément que les gens
qui les reprenaient soient tous
anarchistes.
Alors, c'est bah typiquement le
mouvement syndical, disons, est très
fortement marqué par un syndicalisme
révolutionnaire notamment en France et a
une une sorte d'origine comme ça
anarchiste sur l'idée d'être bien séparé
du politique. et aussi pour les dans
l'anarchisme individualiste
l'idée de de l'Union libre qui a été
théorisé par d'autres mais qui se
développe vraiment au moment de de
des pics d'anarchisme individualistes à
la fin du 19e début du 20e et cetera et
cetera. Bon, l'école l'école libre,
plein de de d'autres expressions de la
pensée libertaire.
Et euh et puis euh l'anarchisme connaît
des moments de reflux euh qui
correspondent aussi au reflux des vagues
révolutionnaires. Euh évidemment la
Première Guerre mondiale est un moment
de reflux euh puisque on a d'abord une
partie des anarchistes qui sera lié à
l'Union sacrée euh et donc sont
favorables à la guerre contre
l'Allemagne. notamment Cropotkin,
appelle à la guerre contre l'Allemagne
et puis c'est un moment où on peut faire
taire toutes les autres forme, toutes
les expressions qu'elles soient
minoritaires ou révolutionnaire pour
contribuer à l'effort national dans la
guerre. Et donc on a ces moments de de
reflus mais qui euh débouchent ou vont
avoir des des résurgence l'anarchisme va
avoir des résurgences aussitôt après que
ce soit dans la révolution russe et en
Ukraine avec la Maknov China que ce soit
aux États-Unis avec
Espagne
voilà et puis et puis en Espagne et puis
là aussi deuxème guerre mondiale moment
de reflux et l'après-demè guerre
mondiale l'anarchisme traverse une
fameuse longue nuit de l'anarchisme euh
qui va de 45 aux années 60, au début des
années 60 et qui est où l'anarchisme
n'est plus porté que par quelques
quelques figures.
Et puis là aussi, petit à petit, devant
la redécouverte de ce qui était le le ce
qui se passait derrière ce qui
n'existait pas encore au début, le mur
de Berlin, c'est-à-dire à l'est, le fait
que euh le bolchévisme ou le communisme
à l'aise n'était en réalité qu'un
capitalisme d'État et qu'il imposait une
des domination très forte et n'avait pas
réussi à mettre en œuvre la justice
sociale justement. Mais des gens ont
redécouvert euh se sont réintéressé à
ces autres courants du socialisme et ont
petit à petit redécouvert la pensée
libertaire. Et on voit à partir du des
années 60 et évidemment de manière très
forte en 68 euh ressurgirent euh toute
tout un non seulement un folklore
libertaire euh mais euh euh des grands
auteurs et des références et des une
jeune génération se se réapproprier la
pensée libertaire. Alors pas de manière
totalement pure, parfois en la matinant.
d'autres influences par exemple marxiste
comme Daniel Guérin qui était un un
trotquiste qui va matiner son marxisme
de pensée anarchiste et inventer un peu
le concept de marxisme libertaire comme
il y a une présence aussi très forte de
référence libertaire chez les
situationnistes. C'est pas pour rien que
à travers les détournements comme le
retour de la colonne de routi, ils font
référence à l'anarchisme.
de bord mentionne dans la carte
géographique de ses auteurs préférés, il
met Bakounine dedans.
Évidemment, chez Vanegem, on retrouve
ça. Et puis plus généralement,
l'anarchisme se diffuse. On voit
réapparaître des drapeaux noirs. L'amphi
de la Sorbonne s'appelle l'amphibono.
C'est-à-dire que même les figures les
plus onies de l'anarchisme sont même
elles euh enfin
récupéré remise dans le dans le dans le
circuit. Euh il y a même Ruffin qui
raconte que en 68 donc Jean-Christophe
Ruffin euh l'auteur euh qui raconte dans
son autobiographie que euh il est allé
chercher dans les sous-sols de l'école
de médecine le cerveau de Ravachol et
que en 68 il est allé mettre le cerveau
de Ravachol
au Panthéon. Donc là où sontù doivent
être mis les grands hommes. Donc Ruffin
qui n'est quand même pas
aujourd'hui
un révolutionnaire accompli. Ben en 68
même lui en quelque sorte alors geste de
provocation, geste je sais pas quoi,
enfin en tout cas il a ce il va chercher
le cerveau de Ravachol et il le met au
au panthéon. Et donc voilà et puis
autour de ça c'est plus généralement
même l'industrie du spectacle. Il y a en
68 un film sur Bonau qui sort dans
lequel joue Jacques Brê.
Il y a Jodassin qui fait une chanson sur
Bonau. Il y a voilà plus et et puis
finalement tout le monde dans les années
70 on arrive à se dire anarchiste.
Sartre dans une interview au Nouvels je
crois que c'est en 74 dit si on relit
toute mon œuvre j'ai toujours été
anarchiste et même tout le monde le sait
pas même Jean-Marie Le Pen qu'on ne peut
pas accuser quand même d'être un un
révolutionnaire le couteau entre les
dents. Jean-Marie Le Pen fait son
mémoire sur le mouvement le courant
anarchiste en France de 1945 à nos
jours. Çaappelle son mémoire qu'il fait
au début des années 70, je crois qu'il
le soutient en 72.
mémoire assez intéressant qui est très
emprunté de livres qui ont été faits à
ce moment-là sur l'histoire du courant
libertaire mais mais mémoire informé
quand même et il le justifie en disant
quelque sorte que en France le danger
n'est pas rouge, il est noir et que donc
on doit s'interroger et s'intéresser à
l'anarchisme puisque en réalité la
révolution qui pourrait venir en France
ce serait pas une révolution rouge, ce
serait une révolution libertaire et que
la tradition française
l'esprit français serait plus proche de
Proudon que de Marx.
Et donc on voit bien ces phénomènes de
résurgence et pareil en 89 on a vu une
espèce de de vague contre
révolutionnaire. Certains ont même
prophétisé la fin de l'histoire et
pourtant dans les années qui ont suivi,
on a vu un mouvement
révolutionnaire contre renaître très
fortement et et très teinté de d'esprits
libertaires que ce soit au Mexique
derrière la figure sans visage du
sous-commandant Marcos
mais aussi évidemment dans les
contresommets de gène avec la
l'apparition
des Black Block, l'organisation des ades
et cetera jusqu'à des groupes dont on ne
sait pas si les individus qui en font
partie se se disent anarchistes mais
dont on auquel on colle assez facilement
l'étiquette d'anarchiste, ce soit le
comité invisible
et d'autres et d'autres organisations.
Discrédité pour mieux étouffer. C'est
ça.
Tu me dis ça sur le le le ben
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une tendance
taxer les gens d'anarchistes. Il y a
alors il y a une tendance qui est faite
qui euh effectivement alors dès qu'on
veut euh disons criminaliser un groupe,
c'est vrai que le pouvoir et en général
la presse vont avoir tendance à le à le
taxer d'anarchiste. Et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que petit à petit, on voit le
le mot libertaire euh euh s'imposer un
petit peu plus même dans les courants,
dans le mouvement anarchiste. Parfois,
on peut avoir des gens qui vont avoir
plus facilement tendance à se définir
comme libertaire puisque l'anarchisme ce
serait le poseur de bombe. Alors
évidemment là, il faut revenir sur
l'histoire,
c'est des Jacques qui inventent le terme
libert
et en fait c'est une une critique qu'il
fait à Proudon, c'est que Proudon était
très misogyne et sexiste et déjà que
considérait que on ne pouvait pas
laisser en dehors de la pensée
libertaire évidemment les femmes. Et
donc il disait que
Proudon était en gros anarchiste à 50 %
et que lui comme il l'était à 100 % il
était libertaire. Donc en fait
libertaire c'est être plus anarchiste
que le père de l'anarchisme.
Et mais aujourd'hui on a un peu cette
idée que libert,
plus sociétal et anarchiste plus dur.
Alors, on le voit très bien pour au
moment de la de la raf, les affiches qui
sont mises placardées en Allemagne euh
qui mettent les têtes à prix des
premiers membres de la de la RAF euh
sont marqués en recherche ces dangereux
anarchistes.
Dans le même ordre d'idée, évidemment,
Action Directe est très souvent taxé
d'anarchiste, ce qui est pas totalement
faux puisqu'il y a une présence de
militant ancien militant libertaire au
sein d'Action directe. Et évidemment, on
l'a vu de manière très forte au moment
de l'arrestation
disons du des groupes coupas comme
disait le le le la presse, avec les
fameuses anarcoautonomes qui déraillent.
Donc effectivement, c'est une manière de
de de faire de faire sentir une menace
et ça c'est presque ça parle presque à
notre cerveau reptilien puisque l'idée
que l'anarchiste pose des bombes, on l'a
depuis le 19e siècle. cette
internationale noire, ces anarchistes
menaçants venant souvent de l'extérieur
ou en lien avec l'extérieur. Bon ben,
elle a été créée
à au moment de à la belle époque et et
donc toutes les lois liberticides ou
c'est les rates euh que que permettent
ensuite de mettre en place ce type de de
de criminalisation ou de menace.
Donc les lois céléérates, c'est quoi ?
Alors, les lois c'est les rates, c'est
les lois qui sont votées. Alors là,
maintenant, je vais plus avoir
exactement les dates en tête parce que
maintenant ça commence à remonter euh
mais qui sont votés dans le courant des
années 1880 euh ou 80 peut-être 92 donc
je suis pas précis, les gens
vérifieront. Bon, c'est
2438 qui t'écoute en ce moment en
direct.
Voilà. Bah très bien. Bon ben donc ils
pourront ils pourront vérifier euh donc
dans les euh dans les années 80 90 1800
euh contre le péril anarchiste et donc
ce sont des lois qui sont en fait les
euh euh les lois euh
qui vont inspirer jusqu'à nos
législations terroristes. Certaines des
lois célérates vont être abolies
seulement enfin remplacées par d'autres
seulement dans les années 80. En gros,
ça crée l'association de malfaiteurs,
c'est-à-dire cette idée que des gens qui
se réunissent pour faire un crime, on
peut criminaliser l'ensemble du groupe.
Voilà. Et don et euh donc à ce
moment-là, il y a aussi euh il on ne
peut pas euh on interdit les
publications anarchistes. Donc le mot
libertaire prend euh un se fait mieux
connaître à ce moment-là. On préfère
dire libertaire.
aux États-Unis, ces lois célérates,
elles vont effectivement donner
l'obligation de définir de de de dire
son appartenance ou non à un groupe
quand on rentre aux États-Unis, chose
qui a duré, je crois que maintenant ça y
est plus. La dernière fois que je suis
allé aux États-Unis, je crois pas avoir
dû remplir ce petit papier. Mais euh
quand
touché rectal ou pas du tout ?
Non, quand j'y allais dans les années
euh 80 90, on devait dire si on était
anarchiste ou communiste quand on
entrait aux États-Unis. Euh si on avait
été membre d'une organisation anarchiste
ou communiste.
Donc tu fais tu fais référence.
Donc ça ça remonte vraiment ça remonte
aux lois des années 1880 90.
Tu fais référence à la guerre contre la
terreur, la guerre contre le péril noir.
Est-ce que maintenant au 21e siècle tu
vois des lois qui peuvent s'apparenter à
ces lois célérates ?
C'estàd l'histoire
de la d'abord l'histoire du maintien de
l'ordre n n'est qu'une histoire de de
loi de ce type. On a eu les lois
anticasseurs après 68 qui permettaient
de de d'attraper n'importe qui avait
participé dans une manifestation où il y
avait eu un trouble à l'ordre public et
de et de sanctionner la personne qu'on
avait attrapée pour l'ensemble des
crimes et des lits qui auraient été
commis dans la dans la manifestation.
C'était quand même les lois anticasseurs
d'après 68 qui sont abolies avec Mitéran
et en réalité assez rapidement remise en
place. Euh alors je me rappelle plus
exactement de de ta question, mais on a
les toutes les lois, les fichiers S, les
lois antiterroristes,
euh les gardes à vue de on sait pas
combien de jours. Alors, c'est très
drôle puisque là en ce moment, je suis
en train de travailler donc sur le le 3è
épisode de l'histoire de l'anarchisme et
notamment là en ce moment, je travaille
sur la la période qui qui concerne
Action Directe et je regardais dans les
archives que il y a la décision quand la
droite revient au pouvoir en en 86, la
décision de d'augmenter pour les
terroristes la garde à vue de 24h à 48h.
Donc d'abord, ce qui est très drôle,
c'est que aujourd'hui on s'est habitué à
ce que les terroristes ai euh voilà et
et 4 jours de de garde à vue. Donc là à
l'époque c'est de 24h à 48h et et il y a
à l'époque des gens qui disent à gauche
principalement que ça va contre l'état
de droit, ce qui aujourd'hui personne ne
penserait à dire ça.
Voilà. Donc on on crée des lois
spéciales à ce moment-là pour pouvoir
faire des gardes à vu de 48 he en le
justifiant d'ailleurs en disant "Oui,
mais comme les organisations terroristes
sont des organisations internationales,
il y a l'euroterrorisme, on parle pour
action directe liée à la raf, aux
brigades rouges, aux basques et cetera."
Et bien comme c'est long d'avoir des
informations à l'international au début
des années 80, euh et bien il faut que
les juges et et la police a plus de
temps pour pouvoir enquêter pendant que
le le le prévenu qu'on appelle inculpé à
l'époque euh est est en garde à vue. Le
garder à vue est en garde à vue. Et donc
évidemment on imagine bien que à
l'époque, je sais pas moi, pour avoir
des renseignements de l'Allemagne, ben
effectivement il y a pas de fax, il y a
pas d'internet. Donc on doit faire des
coups de fil, peut-être des courriers,
envoyer des gens là-bas, revenir et
tout. Ce qui est fou, c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a eu une accélération
de la communication et pourtant la
raison pour laquelle on a augmenté de 24
heures la garde à vue euh n'est plus du
tout à l'ordre du jour. C'est-à-dire
queon devrait se dire "Bon ben
aujourd'hui, on peut rapidement avoir
des informations même de la
Nouvelle-Zélande et donc on pourrait
réduire le temps du de de la garde à
vue." Ben non, on les a étendu.
Bien cuisiner,
hein.
Faut bien cuisiner.
Faut bien Exactement, faut bien
cuisiner.
Donc extension, c'est l'extension des
carnet B, c'est ça ?
Voilà. Alors effectivement le le carnet
B c'est vraiment l'ancêtre du fichier S
aujourd'hui. Alors le carnet B pour pour
rappeler au aux gens qui regardent donc
c'est un carnet qui est mise en place à
la à la veille de la de la Première
Guerre mondiale et dont l'idée est de
pouvoir très rapidement
arrêter devant la la l'importance qu'a
pris le syndicalisme en France de
pouvoir arrêter principalement les
leaders syndicaux hein qui il faut se
rappeler que à l'époque le mot d'ordre
c'est si la guerre est déclarée
la la réponse des travailleurs doit être
la grève générale. Et donc pour empêcher
la grève générale en cas de déclaration
de guerre et bien on fait un carnet donc
le fameux carnet B dans lequel sont
répertoriés l'ensemble des meneurs euh
qui pourrai
euh provoquer ou permettre que la grve
générale se fasse et donc empêcher la
guerre. Et donc il faut à tout prix
empêcher les empêcheurs de guerre. Et
donc on crée ce carnet B dans lesquels
on met tout et n'importe qui dedans.
Toute personne qui a crié "Vive
l'anarchie
euh abas la République, vive la sociale"
et répertorier dedans. Donc on on a on
en a mis dans le dans le dans le dans le
documentaire des des extraits. vraiment
euh assez assez drôle et puis mais aussi
très émouvant de de voir c'est des on a
des portraits, on a des noms de gens, on
a ben ils sont ils sont euh fichés donc
on sait quelles sont leur leurs
fonctions et puis on sait où ils doivent
être amenés. Ils sont arrêtés et ils
doivent être amenés le plus rapidement
possible et mis mis en prison.
Et bien, on a sensiblement la même chose
aujourd'hui avec les fichiers s. Je
pense que n'importe quelle personne qui
s'amuse à crier enfin un peu math de
peau et qui s'amuse à crier Allahuakbar
euh un peu trop longtemps et et ficher
et
c'est normal ou c'est pas normal ?
Bah alors alors la question de la norme,
elle est pas alors est-ce que c'est
juste ou pas juste ? Normal. Oui, ça m'a
l'air d'être dans l'ordre des choses.
C'est-à-dire que le phénomène de
fichage, il est il est généralisé. Donc
on fiche de manière généralisée.
Fiché toi ?
Bah je sais pas. Je sais pas.
Tu as demandé ?
Non, j'ai pas demandé.
Comme idéologue de l'anarchisme ? Non.
Non, mais je suis pas du tout idéologue
de l'anarchisme.
Je sais pas. En même temps, moi quoi sur
ton pince ?
Akabetam. en en même temps euh bon moi
mes résultat moi mes activités elles
sont euh très connues. que euh je sais
pas s'il y a tellement besoin de me
ficher ou de me surveiller
particulièrement, mais bon mais euh euh
en tout cas bah ça permet de de ficher S
et alors ensuite on fiche S au nom du
terrorisme comme il le faisait avec le
carnet B, au nom du terrorisme islamiste
hein
de l'écologie peut-être aussi non
hein et voilà et derrière on peut
largement étendre ces fichiers et bon
ben on l'a vu au moment des
manifestations sur la loi travail de la
possibilité d'empêcher des gens d'aller
manifester sous prétexte de l'état
d'urgence en plus. Voilà. Donc mais ça
c'est un un grand un grand classique et
qu'on retrouve à toutes les les périodes
à peu près et dans tous les pays et
évidemment alors là les
révolutionnaires, les libertaires, les
anarchistes au même titre que d'autres
mais sont trouvent leur place dans ces
fichiers.
L'anarchiste se doit d'être un
éducateur, non ? Euh en tout cas, c'est
vrai que une des une des constantes
qu'on retrouve euh dans le courant
libertaire, c'est cette idée que euh il
faut faire un travail de propagande au
sens noble du terme, euh c'est-à-dire
d'un travail d'information et
d'éducation. Et alors ça, depuis le
début euh vraiment très tôt, les
anarchistes publient énormément. Alors,
comme il y a pas de de maître à à
penser,
la publication est très diverse. Tout le
monde s'empare
beaucoup d'anarchistes sont des
typographes aussi Prouon le premier et
donc ils peuvent en quelque sorte comme
ceux qui ont leur leur sites et leurs
moyens de de de diffusion et de
production euh il peut dès le début
écrire et s'imprimer lui-même et se
diffuser. Ben beaucoup d'anarchistes
sont bizarrement typographes. Albert
Libertad de estographe un des grands
anarchistes individualistes de
l'abbutement martre. Maintenant, ils
sont vidéastes. Euh et donc aujourd'hui,
il serait effectivement vidéaste et et
diffuseur sur internet et
participe aux causeries populaires,
organise des bibliothèques,
participe dans les bourses du travail à
de la de la de l'éducation populaire euh
et et avec vraiment une idée de de de de
de
d'activités qui sont très participatifes
comme on dirait aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que on monte des pièces de
théâtre et ce sont les travailleurs qui
vont jouer cette pièce de théâtre sur
des thématiques sociales.
On on on se fait former soi-même en
allant aux causeries populaire, on
débat, on discute et soi-même on va
aller organiser d'autres causeries
populaires.
et les les disons les les grands noms du
courant libertaire sont des des
débatteurs enfin des conférenciers
acharnés qui qui court le monde pour
faire des des conférences et Mc Goldman
et fait des des des
meetings absolument debout sur des
voitures, dans des salles avec des
affichages sur son nom. Et euh ce qui
est assez drôle, c'est que même
certaines de ces de ces conférences sont
payantes. Euh ce qui permet au au
réseau, au milieu, au courant euh de se
de se financer, de s'autofinancer et
donc euh de ne pas dépendre, de ne pas
avoir besoin de de des autres
structures. C'est pour ça qu'on on
essaie d'effacer le courant anarchiste.
Est-ce qu'on essaie de l'effacer des
mémoires ? Est-ce qu'on essaie d'effacer
la culture anarchiste ? Parce que ça
représente un danger pour les pouvoirs
régaliens de l'État.
Alors moi mon mon analyse enfin que je
partage avec d'autres, c'est que cette
cet effacement de la de l'anarchisme
n'est pas seulement le fait disons du
pouvoir et de l'État ou si on disait de
la bourgeoisie
dans il il est aussi le fait du
si on voulait le le l'appeler comme ça
de du du bolchévisme.
C'est-à-dire que le marxisme, l'élinisme
qui a voulu s'imposer comme seule
pensée sérieuse du socialisme a eu
tendance à nier euh toutes les autres
formes d'expression du socialisme et
évidemment pour imposer là aussi son
hégémonie
au au sein des au sein de
l'international et ensuite des partis
communistes avec les partis communistes
et dans les dans les partis communistes.
puis avec les partis communistes après
puisque par exemple le parti communisme
en communiste en France à ses débuts euh
intègre des militants anarchiste euh et
euh et il y a des euh il y a il il
reflète assez bien. Il y a un livre qui
vient de sortir, moi que j'ai pas encore
lu mais qui doit raconter ça. J'en ai lu
des des des compte-rendus et à mon avis
ça a l'air très bien. Donc euh je veux
le lire. Alors, je crois que c'est chez
Alors, je sais pas si c'est chez
Libertalia ou chez ou chez
Azan, euh
je crois que c'est chez Libertalia,
une histoire du début du Parti
communiste. Et donc il intègre dedans
différents courants, les différents
courants du socialisme révolutionnaire
dont les anarchistes.
Et donc le but est de prendre
l'hégémonie sur ces partis communistes
et après de prendre l'hégémonie au sein
de du du camp des travailleurs. Et donc
c'est les efforts conjugués des deux qui
vont effacer les anarchistes
et et faire et nier leur histoire. C'est
l'effort conjugué des deux, c'est-à-dire
évidemment de la bourgeoisie qui va
avoir tendance à
à raconter cette histoire là en la
traitant sur le mode du fait d'hivers.
les les anarchistes ne sont que des
poseurs de bombe et de la la le récit,
l'historiographie marxiste marxiste
léniniste ou stalinienne
dont le but va être de dire en fait
l'anarchisme n'est qu'un courant petit
bourgeois spontanéiste euh ou favorable
au lumpen prolétaria et et tout et donc
hitler trotkiste et cetera, enfin avec
tous les mots qu'ils utilisaient à ce
moment-là pour disqualifier euh des
courants qui différents et même opposés.
Voilà,
il y a il y a pas une dissonance
cognitive dans l'anarchisme quand quand
ils se regroupent tous pour faire des
collectivités, des plus grandes
[souffle coupé]
des des des exploitations agricoles sans
barrières pour produire produire
produire produire produire. Est-ce qu'il
y a pas une dissonance cognitive
maintenant au 21e siècle où on rentre en
période de décroissance ? Est-ce que
cette période de décroissance ne va pas
en fait sier les fondements mêmes de
l'anarchisme ?
Alors bah les anarchistes quand ils font
des colonie libertaires, c'est pas du
tout avec l'idée de produire produire
produire produire. C'est pas du c'est
pas c'est pas très productiviste hein.
Cette cette question de la productivité,
on va plus la retrouver en Espagne en 36
au sein des disons des grandes
organisations
présentes à Barcelone et dans la région
de Catalogne dont qui veulent montrer
que avec un fonctionnement libertaire de
la démocratie
réelle dans l'entreprise, la reprise par
le peuple, on peut réussir à la faire
fonctionner aussi bien et en période de
guerre et produire autant
et produire autant. Voilà. Mais en
revanche, je reviens juste pour le dire
sur les colonies libertaires. Non, les
colonies libertaires, c'est vraiment
l'idée de faire ces sessions. C'est euh
on quitte ce monde et on va s'installer.
C'est ceux qui sont à poil et qui font
un peu les babac.
Voilà. Alors, ils peuvent être ils
peuvent être à poil mais ou pas. et on
va s'installer euh dans des régions
moins moins habitées, voir on part à
l'étranger euh euh comme les Italiens
qui vont au Brésil fonder la Colonia
Sicilia euh
en mode Charling Gals. Oui, en quel en
quelque sorte euh et que et qui vont
qu'on va retrouver, c'est pour ça que je
veux faire je veux te faire le lien euh
qu'on va retrouver de manière très forte
euh dans le retour à la terre des années
60 euh qui est très fortement inspiré
par Muret Bookchin qui est un un
anarchiste théoricien du municipalisme
libertaire, ancien trotskiste
qui
découvre la pensée libertaire au moment
de la deuxième guerre mondiale, au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et et comprend que en En fait, c'est ce
qu'il a toujours cherché, cette pensée
anarchiste qui est une lutte contre
toutes les formes de domination et
notamment la domination de la nature et
notamment la domination et
l'exploitation de la nature. Et donc il
est il est très important parfois les
verts qui citent Murbouchin ont oublié
que Murbouchin est un anarchiste
convaincu et évidemment anticapitaliste
et que il serait pas question de de pour
Mur Bin d'aller d'aller dans un
gouvernement. Bon et donc
référence à Nicolas Hou ou quoi alors ?
Non. Bon à tous les les les verrs qui
souvent c'est c'est marrant, il cite
Murbouchine
en disant que ils sont c'est c'est comme
si c'était un verre qui avait qui était
leur ancêtre vert alors que Mur Bchin
c'est vraiment
la pensée
anarchiste la plus enfin pas la plus là
aussi on retrouve du du reclu chez chez
Mury Bookin mais C'est vraiment il
applique son son sa grille de pensée
à l'ensemble du monde en une minute pour
expliquer Mur Bookin parce que c'est
intéressant.
Ouais, c'est intéressant. Mur Bin donc
il est il est communiste, trotkiste,
basé aux États-Unis, à New York et il se
rend compte au lendemain de la guerre
que il y a pas eu la révolution. Disons
que Trotski avait dit que la deuxième
guerre mondiale devait provoquer la
révolution mondiale hein pour aller pour
aller vite. Trotski avait dit il doit y
avoir une révolution mondiale à l'issue
de la deuxième guerre mondiale. Et s'il
n'y a pas de révolution mondiale
comme il y en avait eu comme il y avait
eu un début à la fin de la première
guerre mondiale révolution en Allemagne,
révolution en Russie, révolution un peu
partout. Bon là en Italie
là il n'y a pas de de début de
révolution. Trotski avait dit s'il n'y a
pas ce début de révolution au lendemain
de la deuxième guerre mondiale, alors il
faudra qu'on repense complètement qu'on
qu'on repense nos nos idées. Emmer Bchin
prend un peu trop de ski au pied de la
lettre et décide de repenser les les la
la pensée le le la pensée
révolutionnaire. Et dans ce cadre-là,
euh il se rend compte, il découvre les
les auteurs anarchistes et il se rend
compte que dit-il euh que euh le le le
marxisme et le communisme euh s'étaient
trop intéressé à la question de
l'exploitation et dans exclusivement du
point de vue des de la lutte des
classes. Et et alors Muray Bin
déconstruit un peu tout ça en disant
voilà moi je ne pense pas que le sujet
révolutionnaire ce soit le prolétariat.
Je pense que en gros tout le monde peut
être sujet révolutionnaire
euh parce que en fait derrière
l'oppression
euh bourgeois prolétaire, il y a ou
derrière ou à côté ou en même temps
hein, c'est déjà la pensée de
l'intersection, il y a tout un ensemble
d'exploitation qu'il décide lui
finalement de de ramener à cette idée
d'une domination et donc c'est une
domination entre les sexes, c'est une
domination entre les races, c'est des
dominations au sein de la famille, leur
patriarque
C'est tout un ensemble de dominations
qui sont là et évidemment la domination
disons sociale he bourgeois prolétaire
mais aussi toutes les autres et que il
faut lutter contre toutes ces autres
dominations en même temps. C'est pas
l'une qui permettra de de de détruire
les autres mais c'est tout en même
temps.
et et donc
et donc on peut lutter à une échelle
individuelle
au sein de groupes
affinitaires
et puis en vue dans la perspective d'une
révolution globale, hein. Et donc
évidemment dans ces dominations, il en
rajoute une évidemment ça qui est qui
est la domination de l'homme sur la
nature et sur le vivant et voilà. Alors,
pourquoi je passais par euh Murbouchin ?
C'est parce que Murbouchin euh inspire
très fortement euh le mouvement euh IPI
du retour à la terre. [grognement] Euh
et là aussi, on a des créations de
communautés qui sont évidemment
absolument pas productivistes, bien au
contraire d'ailleurs où l'idée c'est
vraiment plutôt d'être autosuffisant,
euh d'avoir un respect à ce moment-là,
un respect de la nature et cetera. Alors
euh oui, on peut avoir euh euh des
moments euh chez euh dans à certains
moments de l'histoire euh des euh des
questionnements sur le productivisme euh
dans le cadre révolutionnaire qui se qui
se pose. Et là, il faut pas oublier que
en Espagne, je reviens à l'Espagne et la
Catalogne, on est dans ce qu'on appelle
la guerre civile qui est une révolution
libertaire qui doit résister à euh aux
assauts de de de des fascismes ligués à
l'abandon ou au de des démocraties
notamment françaises euh et au coup de
couteau dans le dos euh des Staliniens,
hein. hein. Euh donc là en Catalogne il
faut pouvoir résister et c'est plus une
économie de guerre à ce moment-là qui
est est créé. Il faut pouvoir nourrir
l'ensemble de la population, nourrir le
front. Il faut fondre des il faut
essayer d'avoir des armes puisque les
libertaires n'ont pas d'armes. Ce sont
les Staliniens qui récupèrent toutes les
armes. Voilà,
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu des ministres
anarchistes dans le même gouvernement.
Voilà. Alors, c'est une des raisons he
qui est expliqué qui raconté dans le
documentaire. C'est évidemment un des
points de de très très grosse
controverse
euh et de de débat interminable disons
parmi les historiens puis plus
généralement parmi les anarchistes.
Cette participation, fallait-il ou non
qu'il y ait participation ?
En tout cas, il y a participation et
effectivement une des raisons données,
c'est de pouvoir contrôler l'affectation
des armes, de pouvoir essayer comme
souvent les gens qui vont participer, on
pourrait dire même en quelque sorte les
verts quand ils vont au gouvernement,
c'est pour pouvoir empêcher le lobby
productiviste ou le lobby nucléaire de
faire trop de mal. Bah là, à ce
moment-là, c'est aussi de pouvoir avoir
un œil sur les mennés anti-anarchistes
qui pourraient avoir lieu dans le
gouvernement de coalition de républicain
et donc de pouvoir avoir et en même
temps faut pas oublier que
certains de ces ministresl font quand
même des
actions grâce au fait qu'ils sont
ministres qui sont pas négligeables euh
notamment en direction des des femmes.
Sachant qu'il y a un très fort mouvement
féministe
de combat qui s'appelle Meres libres qui
se crée où vraiment on remet en cause
tout l'ordre patriarcal.
On crée des libératoires de prostitution
donc pendant la la la révolution et une
partie de la guerre civile. Et je crois
que c'est Féica Monsie qui est au
gouvernement qui continue d'appuyer ces
ces ces initiatives qui sont des
initiatives d'en bas mais que le
gouvernement défend et enfin voilà, il y
a plein de de d'initiatives.
L'anarchisme, est-ce que c'est pas un
épiphénomène
en terme d'histoire si on remonte sur
2000 ans ?
Alors euh
la la le premier terme anarchiste, du
moins anarchisme est arrivé à peu près à
quelle époque ? 1850
1870 ?
Ouais. Bah c'est c'est avec c'est avec
Proudon que le terme Alors
alors d'abord l'anarchie comme en ce
moment on parle beaucoup de la
Révolution française à la même époque on
a vu quoi arriver en même temps
? L'anarchisme d'abord, l'anarchie,
c'est une espèce d'insulte qui qui est
très utilisé pendant la Révolution
française. Tout le monde se traite
d'anarchiste. C'est vraiment il y a le
même phénomène qu'il y a avec Punk ou
[__] hein. Je trouve que c'est en quelque
sorte c'est assez intéressant puisque
Proudon reprend un mot qui est presque
une insulte à ce moment-là et lui donne
une valeur positive. Un peu comme les
punks reprennent ce mot punk qui est une
insulte pour lui donner une valeur
positive. comme les [__] avec les [__]
ou ou [__] qui a été une une
réappropriation du terme euh pour euh
essayer de le bon euh donc anarchisme
euh l'anarchie tout le monde se traite
d'anarchiste et d'anarchisme euh c'est
Proudon qui euh le premier va se dire de
manière positive anarchiste. Juste pour
reprendre ta ta question, euh il y a une
un courant parmi les euh les les
gens qui travaillent sur sur
l'anarchisme qu'on appelle anarchiste
inclusif ou anarchiste hétérodoxe
qui est alors par exemple c'est Daniel
Colson qui est quel un un historien
lyonnais qui fait un un travail
intéressant
parce Ce que ce qu'il recherche en fait
c'est en quelque sorte des
protoanarchistes. Alors je le dis pas
avec ces termes sil regarde qui m'en
excuse mais je vais essayer de le
raconter. C'est-à-dire que il
s'intéresse à des les groupements
humains qui ont fonctionné sur les bases
d'un anarchisme sans se dire anarchiste.
Et il montre que il y a en quelque sorte
des ancêtres de l'anarchisme qui sont
très nombreux, très très nombreux. Euh
j'en donne j'en donne deux trois
exemples. Euh mais par exemple les
sociétés indiennes fonctionnaient en
quelque sorte donc des nations indiennes
euh sur les territoires nord-américains
euh fonctionnaient selon des principes
qui n'étaient pas loin du libertarisme,
hein. Euh chaque cellule familiale a été
organisée, faisait ce qu'elle voulait.
C'était de la libre association. Il y
avait un chef.
Il y avait pas de chef contrairement à
ce qu'on croit. Non, il y a des il y a
des sages, il y a des conseils,
il y a des des décisions qui sont prises
en commun, mais
c'est pas luuc, il y a pas grand chef
indien avec ses plumes qui décide queon
part sur le sentier de la guerre, voilà,
et avec son cas lui met de la peine.
Non, non, ce sont c'est les anciens qui
se réunissent en conseil, qui discutent,
mais tout le monde tout le monde est
intégré à cette discussion. Euh
je te pose cette question là en fait
parce que en regardant ton documentaire
euh j'ai fait le parallèle avec
l'utilisation de la machine à vapeur à
grande échelle, c'est-à-dire la capacité
que le prolétariat avait de pouvoir
s'affranchir,
de la masse de travail musculaire et de
la concentration de pouvoir que ça a pu
générer dans dans la bourgeoisie. Donc
tu vois pas une relation de cause à
effet entre l'utilisation de la calorie
et le mouvement libertarien libertaire ?
Euh pas du tout. Non, non, si. Bien sûr.
Alors si, mais ce serait ce serait trop
réducteur de le dire sur l'anarchisme.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que le socialisme
le le socialisme le socialisme n'est en
même temps que le capitalisme. Euh, ça
c'est sûr. L'anarchisme c'est presque
une quand tu le disais, c'est presque
une ou deux générations après. C'est
avec ça dépend aussi d'où on fait naître
le capitalisme puisque Redcker le fait
naître carrément. avec la traite
négrière donc au au 16e siècle. Mais
disons queconomie triangul le le le
capital là au moment de la de la
Révolution française un petit peu avant
et après donc avec Rousseau et puis les
premières manufactures et cetera
derrière c'est là que que naî le
socialisme et que
des travailleurs commencent à prendre
conscience de leur de leurs forces
et puis on commence à avoir des des des
penseurs issus de leur rang comme
Proudon ou euh issu de la de la
bourgeoisie
euh comme Marx qui euh euh ou Bakounin
carrément dans la dans la qui euh euh
vont essayer de penser la la situation
les situations.
Je voulais je voulais dire mais
l'anarchisme on a posé notamment dans le
documentaire enfin pour le documentaire
mais ça n'apparaît pas dans le
documentaire mais on a posé la la
question à Jean-Ive Mollier qui est un
des grands historiens de la de
l'histoire de l'édition un des grands
historiens de l'édition euh le lien
entre la machine à vapeur et la
diffusion de la pensée libertaire en
revanche. Et euh et alors c'était
posé dans le doc ça ?
Non alors on on l'a pas mis dans le doc.
Alors pourquoi ? [grognement] Parce que
justement lui dit "Oui, mais c'est la
diffusion de toutes les pensées qui que
la machine à vapeur, que ce soit le
train ou la ou la ou le bateau euh
permettent." Donc, on a toutes les
pensées qui se développent évidemment
celle-là aussi, mais il n'y a pas de
spécificité. Alors, on a essayé de
regarder un petit peu plus précisément.
Oui, quand même. Euh, on a des syndicats
de docker qui sont très fortement
libertaires. Euh euh euh ce sont les
syndicats les syndicats de docker qui ce
sont les dockers qui amènent
l'anarchisme à Cuba, le premier syndicat
libertaire et un syndicat d'Oker, chose
qu'on retrouve ensuite en Amérique
latine. Donc effectivement, on peut
suivre un petit peu euh les émigrations
et donc suivre un peu les les les
trajets des des bateaux. Euh voilà. Mais
c'était pas c'était pas très concluant
et donc on n pas on n pas on pasé plus
n'était pas [grognement] ma question
n'était pas dans le vecteur de
propagation.
Ouais.
Mais dans en gros l'accès à la calorie
plus facile, ça permet aux gens de
réfléchir un peu plus.
Ouais. Euh
oui, alors c'est vrai puisque on a ce
phénomène par exemple de le fait que un
des un des foyers de l'anarchisme
ce soit la Suisse autour de Besançon et
plus précisément le Val de Saint-Timier
où c'est un profil très particulier de
travailleurs. Et donc là, c'est vraiment
le refuge, la forteresse de Bakounine où
il va créer son international
anti-autoritaire et où il a il a réussi
à convaincre beaucoup de de de
travailleurs donc qui sont des ouvriers
hororslogés. Euh
on embrasse Pontus
qui travaille qui travaille à la ça a un
nom et je vais plus m'en souvenir
maintenant mais bon qui travaille un peu
à la montre et ensuite qu' le vendent et
donc qui sont presque un petit peu leurs
propres patrons qui peuvent décider de
leurs horaires de travail qui peuvent
qui ont une idée de l'indépendance très
forte et de leur de leur de leur de leur
indépendance même au sein de la classe
ouvrière qui se sentent membres aussi
comme d'une aristoc ocratie ouvrière.
Donc tout ça, ça a été des choses qui
sont qui sont discutées, qui sont qui
ont qui ont été discutées, qui sont
encore discutées et c'est sûr que on
voit pas et de l'autre côté Zolal
raconte très bien dans dans Germinal
même si bon c'est une fiction mais
effectivement le le perma ne peut pas
avec ces 12 heures de de de descente au
fond de la mine ne peut pas passer
autant de temps et c'est 7 jours de
travail ne peut pas ne peut pas passer
du temps à réfléchir, à lire, à aller à
des à des conférences. Euh voilà,
on fait le parallèle avec la société
d'aujourd'hui.
Oui. Oui. Oui.
Est-ce que Est-ce que on a une question
qui revient un petit peu de temps en
temps et qui fait bondir certains sur
internet. Est-ce que est-ce que les gens
ont suffisamment de temps maintenant
pour s'intéresser à autre chose que de
la téléréalité pour s'anesthésier le
cerveau ? parce que les gens ont
suffisamment de de capacité cognitive
pour comprendre ce qui se passe.
Alors bon, moi je pars du principe que
les gens ont suffisamment de capacités
cognitives tout court d'ailleurs pour
faire des tas de choses et les périodes
révolutionnes.
Est-ce que comprendre l'économie fait
partie de ces attributs ?
Oui. Oui. Ben
si si les gens comprenaient comment
l'économie fonctionnait
Ouais.
Tu aurais une révolution demain. Non.
Après, la question est de savoir euh
comment est-ce que on quelles sont les
les stratégies mises en œuvre pour
détourner les gens de ça. Mais euh ça me
rappelle la fameuse phrase de de de
Coluche dans Misère. Il suffirait que ça
se vende, il suffirait que les gens
l'achètent pas pour que ça se vende pas.
Euh ça c'est euh c'est euh ouais, on
c'est c'est assez ça ça arrête un peu
toute forme de de
disons de de réflexion là-dessus. Mais
euh ce qui est sûr c'est que il y a un
un phénomène d'éclatement. ce qu'on
décrit les les situationnistes
notamment, mais mais d'autres aussi
euh dans les années 60 et 70 sur la
l'éclatement, l'individualisation,
l'isolement des gens. Effectivement
cette vie où dans un monde donc où tout
est ramené au spectacle et où on est
dans une espèce d'instanté permanente
que favorise énormément d'ailleurs
internet. Donc euh cette instantanéité
euh permanente, euh elle est euh elle
est aussi synonyme d'antimémoire.
euh c'est-à-dire que on zappe d'un d'un
événement à l'autre, euh on s'inscrit
plus dans des durées, ni avant ni après.
Euh on a une espèce de Mais bon, j'ai
l'impression de de de dire des lieux
communs, mais effectivement euh des
portes ouvertes.
Oui. Bah enfin non, c'est pas ça, c'est
qu'il y a il y a des il y a je trouve
par exemple que
le comité invisible le dit enfin raconte
très bien et fait une description de de
notre société qui est absolument
lumineuse
que ce soit dans l'insurrection qui
vient mais dans dans à nos amis sur le
rôle joué par l'urbanisme où ils
reprennent ils poursuivent les les
analyses des situationnistes et de le
Fèvre en montrant
cette cette violence
qui est à l'œuvre dans la mise dans dans
dans les conceptions urbanistiques,
la militarisation de l'espace urbain, la
militarisation de l'espace urbain dans
l'isolement
généralisé, dans l'idéologie qui est
véhiculée à peu près partout euh de
moi je suis moi, je fais ce que je veux,
euh voilà, je m'en bats les couilles et
cetera. Euh donc évidemment tout tout ça
est tout ça est un frein. Un frein à
quoi ? Euh au fait de se rassembler et
de pouvoir discuter. C'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que euh
un événement comme Nuit Debout,
l'occupation des places euh déclenche
ceux qui participent parfois un
agacement de cette palabre euh
interminable. Mais mais euh mais au bout
d'un certain temps, mais au début une
espèce de de joie de se rencontrer. Moi,
je me rappelle, c'était moins à Nuit
debout, mais je me rappelle qu'au moment
des greffes de 95, euh quand Paris avait
été bloqué et que les les gens allaient
dans la rue euh et que tout le monde se
mettait à se parler, il y avait une une
espèce de de joie qui était qui était
partagée. On se rerencontrait
et c'est ça qu'il faut empêcher. Et
c'est en fait c'est la la peur, elle est
que les gens se reparlent, se
rerencontrent qui qui est le début
ensuite pour pour pouvoir penser des
actions communes. Et c'est ça qu'il faut
à tout prix empêcher.
Et donc
qu'ils essayent d'empêcher.
Oui. Oui. qu'ils essayent d'empêcher.
Enfin que voilà. Alors, c'est toujours
c'est toujours des phénomènes de
structure. C'est pas c'est pas des gens
derrière un bureau qui pensent que
tiens, on va faire comme si et ça va
marcher. Il y a pas de de complot
là-dedans. C'est c'est des des
structures qui se mettent en place, qui
fonctionnent et donc on les étend.
Voilà,
c'est pas trop tard.
Pourquoi ? pour faire ça, c'est des
structures où les gens se rencontrent,
les où les gens il y a pas un
individualisme qui a été élevé au rang
de religion et que l'endoctrinement des
populations et on peut plus faire marche
arrière.
Bon, alors d'abord enfin là-dessus, il y
a plusieurs choses. D'abord, il ne faut
pas se penser que français.
Moi, je suis je il m'arrive de voyager
et si c'est vrai que dans les pays
occidentaux,
il y a maintenant une espèce
d'idéologie, une lame de fond qui depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale a fait son
œuvre, il y a beaucoup de pays où les
gens se parlent encore où alors c'est
bah le Nicaragua, c'est
alors moi j'ai beaucoup d'expériences
latinoes. américaine euh mais euh euh de
de de vie de vie solidaire, d'entraide
qui existe où on pour s'emprunter un
marteau, on passe pas par une pour
emprunter le marteau du voisin, on passe
pas par un appli et un et un et un et un
moyen de paiement, hein, parce que
aujourd'hui le ça s'est étendu jusque-l
privatisation de tout continue de
s'étendre, privatisation de nos de nos
imaginaires à travers l'internet, de
notre de notre libido ou de nos
fantasmes par le porno, privatisation de
nos échanges avec nos voisins, avec le
Boncoin et cetera et tout doit être
source de profit. Bon, donc il y a il y
a vraiment c'est un c'est c'est vraiment
un système totalitaire ou globalitaire
euh qui se met en place. Bon, il y a des
endroits ou moins effectivement nous on
est en France au cœur d'une de la de la
de la machine. Enfin, en France au
Royaume-Uni, aux États-Unis, en
Allemagne, on est au cœur de la machine.
Donc c'est sûr que on peut avoir le
sentiment que ce soit trop tard. Alors
pour pour resituer des choses euh dans
leur contexte,
c'est le le fait de se dire "C'est trop
tard, on a plus le temps de se
rencontrer, mais il faut faire quelque
chose." C'est aussi ce qui peut euh
pousser à
l'action individuelle violente. C'est
celle qu'on retrouve à la fin du 19e
siècle euh après l'écrasement de la
commune, les lois célérates.
Enfin donc c'est avant les lois c'est
lesérates mais il y a déjà et ben c'est
Ravachol qui se dit "Ben moi, je vais
faire la justice moi, moi-même puisque
on vient d'écraser une grève à tel
endroit, ben que
voilà et que moi je suis moi j'ai je je
envie de de venger cette grève qui a été
écrasée et donc je vais aller mettre une
bombe. C'est ça que fait Ravachol. Je
vais aller mettre une bombe devant euh
euh devant non enfin Ravachol pardon,
c'est pas c'est pas la grève, c'est euh
Ravachol, c'est les manifestations de
Clichi où les gens qui portaient le
drapeau noir sont arrêtés et donc et
condamnés à de lourdes peines de prison.
Et donc Ravachol va mettre ses bombes
devant chez le procureur, voilà pour le
pour le venger pour venger les les la
manifestation de Clichi qui a été
réprimée très fortement
ce qui a été profondément stupide.
C'est stupide. Alors, c'est stupide ou
c'est pas stupide
et contreproductif ?
Je sais pas. C'est en tout cas à ce
moment-là il l'a il a fait ça. Il a tué
personne dans ce cadre là.
Rappelons rappelons que la violence
anarchiste a fait à peu près 200 morts,
c'est ça ?
Oui, même. Oui, un petit peu. Ouais.
Autour de 200 morts. Oui. Ouais. ce qui
sur une sur une plus d'une vingtaine
d'années, ce qui est ce qui est comparé
à n'importe quel
éphénomène guerrier n'est rien.
Arrêtez de poser des bombes et lisez le
petit manuel de la torture de la CIA,
c'est plus efficace.
Ouais. Euh mais non, mais alors enfin
pour terminer quand même juste là-dessus
euh c'est ce qui fait que que Ravachol
euh pose des bombes. Alors stupide,
c'est moi je pense que il faut je moi je
veux pas mettre de de jugement là-dessus
et dans le documentaire, j'essaie de pas
mettre de jugement. Ce que ce que je
crois qui est intéressant de montrer,
c'est pourquoi il fait ça, dans quelle
logique et comment ceci répond à des
actions réactions.
D'accord. Mais dans d'un point de vue
plus purement opérationnel. Et j'allais
non, j'allais juste j'allais le dire,
c'est on l'a euh on l'a aussi avec le le
phénomène du passage à la lutte armée en
Europe dans les années 70 80 où on a
l'essoufflement de de 68hon
d'une partie disons des des meneurs qui
se fait petit à petit et qui en France
particulièrement rentre dans la gauche
de gouvernement
avec l'élection de Mitteran et Bendit,
non ?
Ben con Bendit, Gesmar,
bah Weber, enfin, je veux dire le le le
le monde politique et notamment à gauche
est fait de est rempli de d'anciens
d'anciens trotskistes et tout qui sont
qui sont allés euh allés au gouvernement
ou dans la gauche institutionnelle.
Euh,
un peu de blé,
je crois pas. c'est que je pense que
enfin je sais pas quelles sont les
motivations, les motivations
personnelles, je les connais pas. En
tout cas, il y a ce phénomène là et à
côté de ça, ceux qui restent fidèles aux
idées qui étaient cell d'une révolution
crèvent dans quel niveau à chaque fois ?
Ben en tout cas, certains qui veulent
que euh précipiter devant ce ce reflux
eth ben il ils passent à nouveau euh eux
aussi euh à l'action euh euh armée.
Après euh pour le moment ce que ça a
montré c'est que dans un cas comme dans
l'autre euh c'est euh donc ces
mouvements n'ont pas été euh efficaces.
Donc là on a
ils ont pu être momentanément avoir une
utilité momentanée mais sur le plus long
terme c'est ils ont pas été efficaces.
Aucune stratégie.
Donc je disais je disais aujourd'hui de
dire et si je termine làdessus enfin je
termine je termine juste là-dessus sur
par rapport à ta question c'est que de
dire il y a pas d'échappatoire il y a
pas on peut être pessimiste et cetera
c'est en quelque sorte se dire bah
finalement ceux qui vont qui voudraient
vraiment précipiter le le moment
révolutionnaire pourrai se dire bon ben
il y a pas d'autres solutions finalement
que je m'y mette moi-même puisque ça
sert à rien de se rencontrer et tout je
pense que à l'inverse je te disais sur
l'hégémonie de
de l'extrême droite, mais moi j'ai une
légère tendance peut-être une croyance
dans les cycles et je et je trouve que
la jeune génération, moi je côtoie dans
ma vie en avec mon groupe de rock, avec
tout ça, les la jeune génération
euh euh je pense que elle est elle est
euh elle est dans un un d'abord elle est
beaucoup plus solidaire que que
peut-être notre génération. Euh elle est
euh elle est euh elle est elle est elle
est beaucoup plus alors idéaliste serait
pas la bonne façon de le dire, mais
disons que elle revient à des principes
euh de gauche ou d'extrême gauche ou
révolutionnaire.
Elle s'intéresse à ces questions-là.
Elle retrouve aussi une histoire
et son histoire et il y avait une espèce
de sondage qui avait été fait pour un
projet audiovisuel qui s'appelait
génération quoi ? génération wat à
l'échelle européenne. Bon, on croit pas
au sondage mais je trouvais que c'était
hyper intéressant les réponses qui
avaient été apportées. C'était que euh
en gros euh 90 % de des 15 15 35 ans euh
ne croyaient plus la télévision. Euh 65
% ne croyaient plus en l'action
politique, dans le fait de voter que les
élus allaient changer quelque chose et
cetera. Alors, il y a il y a les les
chiffres sont sur internet de ce mais je
trouvais ça très intéressant de voir que
cette jeune génération est très critique
et et éprouve le l'envie de d'un
changement d'un changement profond. et
et un dans le ce sondage euh il y avait
55 % de cette génération qui se
définissait comme anticapitaliste. Ce
que je trouvais intéressant là aussi,
c'est-à-dire que
aussi, il y a aussi euh le le ying et le
yang de ça, c'est aussi un un repli
identitaire vers l'extrême droite.
Ouais.
Qui se qui se matérialise énormément en
ce moment, non ? Oui. Oui. Alors moi
j'aime bien une expression d'Edoui
Plenel qui dit que le poisson pourrit
par la tête et je crois que le la
question de l'extrême droite c'est pas
des Louis Plenel ça. Non
non non mais c'est c'est Louis Plenel
qui le dit et euh sur ce
d'un chinois il a ch hein. Ouais
peut-être. Ah oui c'est vrai. Ouais. et
euh euh et qu'il le dit là euh
c'est-à-dire que je pense que c'est un
un l'extrême droite, ça a été disons
euh sans faire du du Gramchi, mais comme
ils avaient lu Gramchi et qu'ils sont
inspirés de Gramchi, ils ont essayé de
conquérir les anciens de l'extrême
droite, enfin les ceux qui étaient
d'extrême droite dans les années 70-80
ont essayé de conquérir des des euh des
lieux de pouvoir et de diffusion de
leurs pensées. Et donc on le voit,
ils font leur cré maintenant, ils font
leur université.
Voilà. Et donc et donc maintenant c'est
des bibliothèques, des universités.
Alors attention, l'extrême droite c'est
pas forcément celle qui dit son nom
hein. Zemmour ne dit pas son nom
d'extrême droite. Pourtant on est dans
de la pensée d'extrême droite. Mais on a
la chaîne Histoire qui est dit toujours
dirigée par Patrick Buisson.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi Zemour c'est un
c'est un penseur d'extrême droite ?
Bon, il est il tient un discours
xénophobe et islamophobe qui est quand
même
très violent.
Il est dans une espèce de de désir du
chef
avec un culte de la avec je pense
derrière une idée que il faut un chef
avec culte de la personnalité.
Euh ouais, enfin moi à mon avis
aujourd'hui il est vraiment il est
vraiment péténiste avec une régénération
de la jeunesse. Enfin c'est vraiment de
de c'est un discours péténiste quoi qui
historien.
Bah non là il fait il fait plutôt œuvre
d'idéologue Zemour
comme tout historien.
Oui alors oui oui mais enfin Zour se
prétend pas historien. Euh il peut y
avoir de l'idéologie dans tout il y a de
l'idéologie dans tout discours
différendre la main à l'extrême droite.
Non mais euh c'est bizarre comme
question.
On arrive à la fin. On va on va te
chauffer un peu.
Euh non mais enfin euh euh le Non mais
attends parce que tu me poses avec il
faut tendre la main l'extr Non. Euh
je sais plus ce que je voulais dire dans
buisson tout ça. Donc il y a il y a une
prise Ouais. Il y a une prise, il y a
une prise de contrôle
et cette prise de cont du rôle et cette
diffusion de la pensée. Oui, voilà,
c'est ça. C'est que c'est au c'est au
niveau supérieur pour pour dire
reprendre les trucs. C'est la France
c'est la France d'en haut qui se
péténnise. Je ne suis pas sûr que la
France d'en bas, comme on dit, se
péténnise. C'est la France d'en haut. Et
elle essaie de diffuser sa pensée par
tous les moyens, tous ces moyens de
communication, ça c'est sûr.
Et la France san, elle fait comment pour
propager ses
sa façon de penser ? Ben ben bah
de dans dans ta société de production,
tu essayes de
Ben voilà, mais on a on a le on a on a
alors ma société de production est un
est un épi est un épiphénomène euh à
côté de du travail que font bah lundi
matin
la fabrique Agone, Libertalia, donc des
des éditions parce queil faut voir aussi
que disons de notre côté, on a aussi des
des des
maisons d'édition, des organes de
diffusion le vôtre aussi euh qui euh bah
sont de plus en plus populaires et et
touchent de plus en plus de monde. Et
bon ben moi j'apporte enfin où j'ai
essayé d'apporter une petite pierre à
l'édifice avec le documentaire sur
l'histoire de l'anarchisme et puis plus
généralement avec les documentaires
qu'on produit
au sein de de ma société mais enfin de
notre société d'ailleurs. pas du tout la
mienne de notre société, mais euh euh
c'est on on n pas euh la même
aujourd'hui on n pas la même puissance
très clairement que
la que ne l'on ces gens de droite ou
d'extrême droite qui qui tiennent les
lieux compagnie, c'est
qui tiennent le pouvoir culturel quoi.
Donc revenons à la question, est-ce
qu'il faut tendre la main à l'extrême
droite ?
Bah non. Enfin, pourquoi on tendrait la
main ? Je comprends même pas pourquoi
entendrait là les déradicaliser.
Ben non, mais c'est-à-dire que moi je
pense que euh le tu me disais tout à
l'heure mais ça parce que je pars moi
d'une j'ai un côté roussoauiste dans le
fond, c'est-à-dire que je pense que les
gens sont sont bons et que si on a la
possibilité de leur expliquer
tranquillement les choses euh ils les
ils les comprennent euh et ils les
partagent et eux-mêmes apportent leurs
pierres et cetera. Je crois que les gens
enfin disons que pour le dire autrement
et ça ça repose aussi sur une pensée de
de de Bakounin euh face à l'idée d'un
d'une sorte de darwinisme darwinisme
social où on serait tous en guerre les
uns contre les autres, toutes les
entreprises en guerre contre les unes
contre les autres, les humains, les
peuples et cetera et en guerre et en
compétition, les races, les religions et
tout ça. Ce que Kropotkin a essayé de
montrer dans l'entrée dans la nature,
c'est de montrer que la la nature était
finalement beaucoup plus basé sur
l'entraide que sur l'idée de de la
compétition et de la lutte à mort. Et je
pense que
les les là, on rentre presque dans de
dans de la la philosophie. Enfin l'homme
l'homme l'homme étant un animal social
euh et euh qui euh a un phénomène
d'empathie qui est qui est presque
premier euh chez euh chez nous. Euh
c'est ça vient de Rousseau, on le
retrouve chez Schopenhauer. Euh
Arthur.
Ouais. Euh donc normalement c'est c'est
là-dessus que devrait se baser une
société. Après, on a voulu la remplacer
par un culte du profit et de
l'accaparement et de l'isolement.
La propriété, c'est le vol.
La propriété, oui, c'est Oui, c'est le
vol. Oui, oui, oui.
Parle-nous un peu d'Orwell.
Euh, ben je sais pas quoi dire.
Qu'est-ce que Pose-moi
commence par le début ? [grognement] Ben
euh
ce qui est euh
bon ce qui est intéressant euh je sais
pas je [rires] sais pas quoi dire. Euh
bah c'est un c'est un formidable
visionnaire euh
les mondes
d'écrit ressemblent enfin là je vraiment
je je suis je suis pas
Est-ce que tu as lu la ferme des animaux
?
Je l'ai je l'ai vu et on l'a lu avec ma
fille. Enfin c'est plutôt ma compagne
qui l'a lu à ma fille. Ouais.
Est-ce que tu fais le parallèle avec la
société du 21e siècle ?
Euh
oh là là, moi là ça remonte. Alors il y
a le le cochon, c'est une description.
Oui. Alors voilà, parce que moi je l'ai
vu, je crois que c'est le dessin animé
hein que j'ai vu. Donc il est très
édulcoré je pense.
Ouais ouais hein. Il est très édulcoré.
Euh
mais enfin oui. Oui. Voilà, je te
réponds. Oui.
D'accord.
Voilà. Mais je l'ai pas lu. Je l'ai pas
lu la
1984 c'est c'était censé être un manuel
ou pas ?
84 c'est incroyable comme c'est une bon
enfin là je dis vraiment je dis une
banalité mais enfin c'est euh c'est une
une vision prophétique. Non voilà je
sais pas quoi dire.
On passe aux questions d'internet.
[soupir]
C'est-à-dire que la description du
discours, moi ce qui m' me marque le
plus aujourd'hui, c'est comment il a
deviné le discours schizophrénique qui
deviendrait absolument la norme
aujourd'hui.
Le faire la paix pour faire la guerre.
Alors, je me rappelle plus comment sont
les termes dans 84, mais euh la paix
Ouais, la guerre, c'est la paix et
cetera. Et aujourd'hui, c'est euh le
disons le discours spectaculaire euh est
est un discours comme ça. Et j'avais un
ami et qui euh qui est mort il y a pas
longtemps euh qui était euh
schizophrène, léger et qui me disait
"C'est fou queon me dise que moi je suis
fou
alors que ces discours là sont des
discours de fou qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre."
Tu sais la différence entre un fou et
quelqu'un qui n'est pas fou ?
Non. C'est que nous on sait qu'on est
pas fou.
Ah oui ouais c'est ça. Ouais d'accord. H
question d'internet. Où sont les
mouvement anarchiste aujourd'hui ? Qui
sont-ils ? Sous quelle forme ?
Alors bah bon, c'est c'est une question
qui est qui est hyper intéressante et je
pense que d'abord il faut pas se poser
la la question en ces termes,
c'est-à-dire que on n'est pas à la
recherche
d'un enfin faut pas non disons que moi
moi en tout cas je me la poserai pas en
ces termes. La question du label n'est
pas une une bonne question. Euh c'est la
question de quelles sont les idées et
quelles sont les pratiques qui est une
question fondamentale
pour le dire et ça ça rejoint disons le
travail que je fais sur le le 3è épisode
ce que je j'essaie de montrer dans le 3è
épisode que je suis en train de faire
qui va sortir quand
donc j'espère que il sera fini pour
février et sans doute pour mai.
le financement.
Alors pas totalement le financement mais
n'ayant ne venant plus définitivement,
on le fait avec la chaîne parlementaire.
Figure-toi et figurez-vous. Voilà. Mais
qui avait diffusé déjà le commence à
sortir, il commence à se sortir un peu,
passez-moi l'expression, il commence à
se sortir un peu les doigts du cul. Ils
ont fait un truc sur Alstom qui était
pas mal du tout. Oui oui mais mais
Isabella Pisani qui fait les
documentaires à la chaîne parlementaire
d'ailleurs enfin est très très bien et
quelqu'un de très bien qui est vraiment
très intéressé par tous enfin la la
variété la diversité des discours, la
diversité des histoires. Donc elle a pas
de de d'idéologie elle propre et donc
elle s'intéresse suivant voilà parlement
quoi. Et comme ça avait bien marché sur
la chaîne parlementaire, ben on s'est
dit bon enfin, elle m'a dit "Bon, allez
viens, on fait le 3, on s'en fout, on
attend pas de toute façon comme viendra
pas." Euh je sais plus. Oui, je crois
qu'il faut plus poser. Alors, disons que
ce que je raconte dans le 3è épisode où
ce que j'essaie de montrer, c'est
comment à la à la charnière justement de
ces années 70 80 avec tout le monde qui
se dit anarchiste y compris donc Sartre,
même le Pen fait son mémoire et puis la
confiscation même par des gens qui ne
sont plus anarchistes euh du terme euh
des termes anarchistes comme Daniel
Conbendit qui continue de se dire
libéral libertaire, disons faisant
perdre
euh sa sa définition même au au terme de
libéral au terme de libertaire que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure. En fait, Daniel
Comendit, il est libéral, il est il est
plus du tout libertaire. il est libéral
au sens disons libéral sociétal et
libéral économique du terme euh et euh
euh mais aussi au mouvement le mouvement
libertarien euh aux États-Unis qui est
en en réalité euh euh disons de
l'ultralibéralisme mais qui a confisqué
le mot libertaire libertarien
pour en faire le synonyme de de ça. Donc
entre cette confiscation du terme
libertaire disons et la la
criminalisation du terme anarchiste et
puis plus généralement la
criminalisation de toutes les formes de
résistance. Bien, il y a une tendance
qui est apparue à partir des années 90 à
ne plus vouloir se définir, se dire ou
se définir. Et donc on le voit assez
bien disons de manière là aussi
spectaculaire chez le sous-commandant
Marcos donc qui vient d'une tradition
marxiste léniniste guévariste
mais qui au contact des populations
indiennes au Chiapas matine très
fortement son son guévarisme
d'une de pratique et d'idées
protoanarchiste mais aussi magoniste
hérité de la révolution mexicaine. Merci
de Flor Magon du Mexique. Et donc on
voit des des pratiques, les caracoles,
tout ça qui sont vraiment les les
conseils, l'organisation,
le fait que le commandant ne soit pas
commandant mais sous-commandant, que ce
soit lui le peuple qui commande et lui
qui obéit, enfin tout ça, le fait qu'il
ne montre pas son visage, donc de
vouloir des personnifier même si ça
personnifie quand même et cetera. Donc
l'idée de de disparaître, c'est aussi
assez révélateur, même s'ils
n'appartiennent pas à une euh même s'ils
ne se disent pas anarchiste, mais le
fait que le comité euh se invisible se
dise invisible lui-même, hein.
C'est foutu maintenant avec la big data
hein, de de ne pas vouloir de ne pas euh
de ne pas se faire connoter.
De ne pas se faire connoter. Oui, mais
après il y a le choix par exemple euh
euh il y a il y a vraiment cette idée
qui est de de ne plus vouloir se définir
et puis
mais c'est foutu avec ça.
Ben euh alors c'est-à-dire moi par
exemple qu'on parce que j'ai fait un
documentaire sur l'anarchisme donc
je te prends tes datas. Non non mais moi
moi on me prend très anarchiste. Alors
moi pour raconter aussi, moi j'ai milité
à lutte ouvrière
et je ne suis pas
Ce n'est parfait hein.
Non non mais mais c'était une expérience
de de de d'apprentissage
tu as fait la bisarlettre.
Non non non mais mais j'étais voilà dans
c'est quoi le slogan ? travailleus
travailleur
oui mais bon ça c'est la la la version
là aussi disons un peu un peu bah là
aussi spectaculaire de de lutte ouvrière
lutte ouvrière c'était aussi c'était
aussi et surtout moi ce dont j'avais
envie à ce moment-là c'était peut-être
je ça a été un un hasard de circonstance
mais c'était aussi j'avais envie de lire
des textes et de discuter de ces textesl
avec des gens qui les avaient l alors
j'aurais pu être ailleurs. Bon, il s'est
trouvé que là, il y avait une espèce de
rigueur, moi qui me plaisait.
C'est à cause de papa,
hein.
C'est à cause du papa.
Non, non, pas du tout. Non, non, pas du
tout. C'est lutte ouvrière. Non, c'est
J'avais un mon meilleur ami euh à
l'époque qui était à Lut Ouvrière et qui
en partait quand moi j'ai commencé à
C'est quoi son nom ?
Non, alors je le dirai pas parce que
maintenant il est plus du tout là-dedans
et euh et voilà. Il est plus du tout
là-dedans. Je sais pas, c'est ça les que
je dise. Autre question d'internet.
Est-ce qu'on peut être
anarchocapitaliste ?
Alors euh bon, évidemment non. Euh
voilà, c'est ça rejoint l'histoire des
libertariens. L'anarcoapitalisme, c'est
vraiment un oxy mais qui n'est pas qui
ne fait pas sens.
Il a été inventé par qui ce terme ?
Ah, je sais plus.
Mer Rodbar.
Voilà.
Euh donc euh
l'anarcocapitalisme c'est vraiment euh
on est dans l'extrême de ce que je te
disais sur le le libertarien.
C'est-à-dire que bon le capitalisme il
s'est créé sur l'idée que la propriété
c'est le vol euh sur l'idée de la
destruction de toutes les formes de
domination. ces formes de domination,
c'est la domination, l'exploitation et
la domination économique, euh la
l'exploitation et la domination
religieuse euh et euh et donc euh euh
euh évidemment euh non, on ne peut pas
l'anarcocapitalisme en fait c'est un
masque pour cacher l'ultralibéralisme là
aussi.
Pourquoi le troisème docu n'est pas
diffusé par censure de l'anarchie
aujourd'hui ? Euh alors moi moi j'ai
jamais eu d'explication d'Arté euh sur
le pourquoi euh il prenait pas le 3è
épisode. C'est euh je crois que c'est le
seul ça performé pourtant
c'est Ouais c'est le Ah oui oui ça a
très bien marché. C'est le seul cas
d'une série d'histoires qui n'est pas
allée à son terme. Alors il y a eu
beaucoup de changements dans les
directions euh à ce moment-là au moment
où où on où on livrait les deux premiers
épisodes. Mais disons que j'ai jamais eu
d'explication clair de pourquoi ils ont
pas pris.
Est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille chercher
l'explication ? Euh
tu peux aller chercher l'explication. À
mon avis, tu auras euh tu auras des
explications de forme du genre euh ceci
ne correspond pas à notre ligne
éditoriale ou ce genre de choses, tu
vois, où on avait plus de budget ou ce
genre de truc.
La violence dans la pensée anarchiste.
Ouais. Alors bah la violence dans la
pensée anarchiste, c'est-à-dire que bon
mais on connaît ça évidemment. On a
souvent dit que il y avait de la
violence dans la pensée anarchiste et
dans les et dans certaines pratiques
anarchistes évidemment. Et les
anarchistes ont souvent et tout presque
toujours répondu que euh
la violence elle se trouvait évidemment
dans la société, dans l'exploitation euh
et qu'il y a des violences beaucoup plus
massives mais qui sont légitimées par
l'ordre et que on essaie de délégitimer
la violence euh
des révolutionnaires. Et donc il y a là
il y a un travail de relégitimation de
la violence des révolutionnaires et de
délégitimation
ou légitimisation de la violence alors
étatique patronale et cetera.
Si je te dis la violence c'est la force
des faibles et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances ? Mais je pense que
l'histoire de cette question de la
violence dont on veut absolument faire
un curseur, enfin, elle n'est pas elle
fonctionne pas d'abord parce que
violence, c'est un peu comme terrorisme,
c'est un peu comme des tas d'autres
choses. Euh c'est complètement
spongieux. Donc euh donc la violence
c'est pas c'est pas plus la force des
faibles que la la faible la la la la la
faiblesse des forts ou je sais pas quoi.
Euh et puis d'abord, on parle de quelle
violence ? Je rappelle que il y a des
violences psychologiques, il y a des
violences physiques, il y a enfin bon il
y a il y a tout il y a tout types de
violence. Euh
les black block, c'est quoi ?
Le Black Block, c'est un un pratique une
pratique spectaculaire dans le cadre de
la société du spectacle euh dans lequel
une action symbolique de regroupement de
gens euh en vue de mener des actions
symboliques qui font passer un message
et dont le but est dans la zone dans
laquelle
ce cortège se crée de réussir à créer
d'autres formes de relation
là aussi de solidarité,
d'entraide,
d'égalité, de liberté et cetera. Moi, je
compare beaucoup pour être souvent là
le le le cortège de tête à
cordé. Moi, je le compare à ce qui se
passe aussi parfois dans le dans le
pogo. Euh
le pogo, ça nous rajunit pas tout ça.
Ouais, tu vois. Ben maintenant, je sais
pas comment on dit. On dit toujours
Pogo, non ? Mais ça a moins lieu. Mais à
l'époque dans le Pogo, il y avait à la
fois
une espèce de bon, c'était un peu
masculiniste, mais il y avait à la fois
une espèce de de de frottement de de de
contact qui pouvait être dur. Et en même
temps, il y avait une très grande
solidarité. Les gens qui tombaient
étaient ramassés, relevés, ceux qui
s'étaient fait mal mis sur le bord. On
on prenait soin les uns des autres en
réalité. Euh ce qui est très différent
d'ailleurs, c'est assez drôle puisque le
le Pog disons de du dans les groupes
punk est très différent du Pogo O de la
musique skinhead où là ils se tapent
vraiment dessus, ils se font mal. dans
dans le dans le Pogo, il y a il y a un
phénomène plus bon
encore archaïque. Ouais, il y a quelque
chose. un peu de tribal là-dedans et en
réalité une vraie une vraie communauté,
un vrai voilà euh et voilà et et à
l'intérieur du black block ou du cortège
de tête, enfin dans le bloc là euh il y
a c'est je trouve que c'est
c'est c'est un c'est un endroit où à la
fois on est en lutte, où on va
essayer de de d'arrêter la police qui
peut charger de la repousser.
euh essayer de de de dévier la
manifestation pour essayer de la faire
partir en manifestation sauvage. Donc où
on va avoir des stratégie d'affrontement
mais où on va avoir une stratégie de
protection protection non seulement des
gens qui sont dans le cortège de tête
mais même ce qui est souvent perdu de
vue de protection de la manifestation
qui vient derrière.
C'est aussi ça une des idées du Black
Block euh qui a qui est complètement
perdu de vue évidemment quand c'est
raconté dans dans les médias. ou c'est
simplement analysé sur des vidéos. Il y
a une véritable stratégie, tu vois,
c'est peut-être en train d'évoluer.
La stratégie du black block, c'est quoi
?
Bah, c'est celle que je viens de dire.
Ouais,
ouais, ouais.
Le Black Block, c'est à la fois l'idée
de pour défendre une manifestation
euh qui peut être réprimée. Et donc, on
a à l'avant de la manifestation, il faut
se rappeler que il y a il y a 10 15 ans
euh en fait le les les affrontements
avaient lieu à l'arrière de la
manifestation et à la fin sur les
dissolutions de manifestation. Donc il y
a une stratégie qui a évolué, qui a
changé euh qui est on réduit ça à des
autonomes. C'est beaucoup plus large les
gens qui vont dans le cortège de tête et
de plus en plus large parce que on l'a
on l'a même vu au je crois que c'était
au 1er mai où on avait pratiquement
autant de manifestants dans le cortège
de tête que de manifestation que de
manifestants derrière. Je crois que
c'était pour le 1er mai où il y avait
15000 personnes dans le cortège de tête
et je crois que 16000 ils ont parlé de
16000 derrière. Faut remercier les
anarchistes pour le 1er mai. Non.
Euh bah euh non,
ils sont battus pour non.
Ah oui, pour avoir le 1er mai. Ouais.
Euh oui. Alors enfin je sais pas je sais
pas s'il faut remercier les anarchistes
mais en tout cas ça appartient à
l'histoire libertaire. Oui. Puisque
c'est le 1er mai vient de la d'une
répression qui a lieu à à Chicago
dans laquelle des anarchistes sont
arrêtés. les les meneurs qui prennent la
parole suite à une bombe qui est posée
euh a priori a priori par la police
et euh et qui sont condamnés à mort et
c'est en mémoire de cette manifestation
et de ces condamnés à mort les les 5 day
market que le 1er mai va devenir la
journée internationale des travailleurs.
[soupir]
On arrive à à la fin de notre interview.
Euh dernière question internet. Est-ce
que beaucoup de gens se ne seraient pas
anarchiste sans en être conscient ?
Alors ça c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et je je reviens sur ce
que ce que disait Colson. Il y a aussi
d'abord beaucoup d'expériences disons
libertaires et je vais en faire une très
simple que on on a pu tous éprouver dans
notre vie de moments disons d'anarchie.
C'est euh
quand on décide de faire un foot euh à 6
ou à ou à 8 ou ou à ou à 5 ou je sais
pas quoi. Enfin bon, mettons qu'il faut
être le même nombre. On décide que euh
au lieu de faire des grands buts, on va
faire des petits buts. Euh puis il y a
pas d'arbitre, tout le monde va jouer.
Euh mais il pourrait même y avoir un
arbitre. On décide que le terrain
finalement bah il va aller de l'arbre à
là à l'arbre à là et tout puis que
finalement les touches on les joue pas.
euh ou où on joue les touches mais on
les joue au pied et cetera. En réalité,
on est en train de définir des règles
ensemble, de se mettre d'accord dessus
euh sans que personne nous les impose
tous ensemble et pour essayer de de
jouer. Donc on n'appelle pas la
Fédération internationale de football
pour savoir quelle règle on doit
appliquer quand on joue dans son jardin.
On fait pas on demande pas un arbitre
officiel, on on on règle les choses
entre nous.
S'il y a une on est on est dans une
bonne ambiance, s'il y a une une même
blessure,
a priori personne se bat.
On emmène la personne enfin on prend
soin de on prend soin, on essaie
d'ailleurs même qu'il y ait pas de
blessure, on peut même jouer pied nu.
Enfin bon, tout ça pour dire que voilà,
c'est on peut faire une expérience de
euh définition en commun d'une de de
règles qu'on se donne en commun qui
durent le temps de cette de cette de cet
exercice, de ce jeu qui dureront pas
plus longtemps, qu'on ne veut pas
imposer aux autres et qui nous satisfont
nous et qu'on peut même faire évoluer au
cours de la partie. Voilà. Donc oui, en
quelque sorte, on peut vivre des moments
d'anarchie et là c'est plus de
l'anarchisme, c'est des moments
d'anarchie. On peut être amené à en
vivre. Dans le même ordre d'idée, quand
on va emprunter le marteau ou je sais
pas quoi ou un tournevis chez son chez
son voisin ou la perceuse,
ben on lui fait pas un billet avec une
reconnaissance de dette. Il nous demande
pas de l'argent en échange, on lui rend
demain ou après-demain. On essaie de pas
lui casser, de pas lui abîmer. Et puis
si on lui abîme, ben on lui remplace le
truc. Voilà.
Donc là, on définit nous-même nos
règles. Il y a pas de il y a pas de il y
a pas d'échange. On est dans donc on
fait une expérience on on passe pas un
contrat écrit. Bon donc on est dans une
une expérience libertaire. Bon, donc euh
euh oui, on peut on peut ça plus loin
que ça, on peut effectivement, ce que je
disais euh avoir euh euh des pratiques
euh militantes euh ou de défendre des
des euh des causes euh qui sont euh
libertaires ou anarchistes sans le
savoir.
J'ai une j'ai une une
petite sœur qui est très très végane.
Enfin, très végan, ça veut rien dire.
Elle est végane. Bon, elle est végane et
et
très végane.
Non, mais très très très mobilisé autour
de la la
logique.
Non, non, non, non, non, non. Très très
consciente, très mobilisée, très au fait
de ce qu'il faut faire et tout parce
qu'elle elle veut pas acheter des plats
préparés. Donc, elle fait vraiment
prosite prosélite prosélite.
Alors, pas tellement pas prosélite dans
la vie, mais en l'occurrence plusieurs
fois on en a parlé. Voilà. Et euh et
donc moi qui suis un végétarien en
conversion mais depuis 20 ans euh donc
ça ça arrive
un petit peu bourguignon ce soir.
Je suis voilà, je suis totalement
convaincu euh en théorie euh qu'il faut
l'être mais je n'arrive pas encore à
passer à la pratique. Donc là ça fait
vraiment euh voilà mais on a on avait
une discussion et où euh on avait une
discussion sur la sur l'anarchisme. Je
vois laaffiche pour sauver la chasse.
On avait une discussion justement sur
l'anarchisme et je lui disais
enfin on discutait et justement on
discutait sur en fait l'abouti est-ce
que l'aboutissement
de mon mon désir de changement social
ne rejoignait pas l'aboutissement de sa
lutte contre l'exploitation animale ?
La convergence
pourquoi ? Exactement. Fameuse
convergence des luttes, hein. Pourquoi ?
Parce que en fait si on veut arrêter
l'exploitation animale, on est obligé
de en quelque sorte pour aller très vite
d'abolir le capitalisme. Il n'y aura pas
de de défense de la nature de de respect
des droits des animaux euh dans une
économie capitaliste. Euh donc qui est
par définition un système totalitaire où
tout est ramené à un prix euh et à
l'idée que on va pouvoir euh l'échanger
et le consommer. c'est ça ne ça ne
fonctionne pas. Donc il faut pour
défendre les droits des animaux, il faut
euh détruire le le capitalisme. Et dans
le même ordre d'idée,
me disait-elle. Effectivement,
l'avènement de la justice entre les
hommes, entre les hommes et les femmes,
ne peut pas se faire avec la la
perpétuation d'une domination
sur les autres animaux avec l'idée que
les hommes et les et les hommes et les
femmes, les humains seraient différents
par nature du règne animal, le règne
humain et le règne animal qui est une
vision complètement en réalité
religieuse.
Donc on fait partie du règne animal et
il faut repenser évidemment et
réenvisager totalement notre rapport.
Je peux je peux te poser une question ?
Autres animaux. Oui.
On se détourne de ta de ta sœur, c'est
ça ?
Ouais.
Végétarienne.
Euh il se passe quoi si on fait tomber
le capitalisme ?
les fonds de pension, les fonds de
retraite,
le les services sur le le nucléaire,
tu sais, les trucs incompressibles qu'on
a mis en place depuis 50 ans qui a
bénéficié à tout le monde, les syndicats
et tout le monde. Il se passe quoi si on
fait tomber ça en en moins d'une semaine
? Hein ?
Il se passe quoi ?
Alors, c'est intéressant hein. Moi, j'ai
travaillé sur des périodes
révolutionnaires
21e siècle. Autant autant non autant sur
la la commune mais sur la révolution
cubaine euh
la commune où 20000 personnes tuées.
Euh ouais enfin la semaine sanglante euh
la répression de la commune. Ouais
ouais. Euh mais attends c'est Ah ah, je
comprenais pas le sens de ta question.
Je croyais que tu me demandais
l'exprimer.
Non, je je croyais que tu me demandais
c'est en fait ce que tu me demandes
c'est quelle quelle va être la réaction
à une tentative révolutionnaire.
Euh bon
et et peut-être un succès.
Ouais bah succès à la fin. Bon il y a de
il y a de très fortes chances que il y
ait une une résistance à ça. Il y a de
très fortes chances.
Après la résistance, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Bah c'est euh c'est la question. C'est
la question. Voilà. C'est la question.
On on sait pas quelle forme
poser la question. Non
non. Bien sûr, mais très intéressant
qu'à chaque fois qu'on discute avec des
anarchistes, on on veut bien discuter,
il y a aucun souci. Mais après la
projection du modèle avec tout ce qu'il
y a derrière, la masse de choses qui a
géré, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Alors, attends, non, j'ai alors
en fait c'est moi qui c'est mal.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va dire au petit vieux
que qu' aura pas sa pension à la fin ?
Non. Ben donc c'était J'avais bien
compris la première fois. Ah pardon.
Alors, j'avais bien compris la première
fois. Alors, je croyais que tu me
demandais quelle réaction il y aurait.
Alors non, c'est pour ça que je te je te
disais euh réaction euh il y a euh au
départ au départ je pensais que tu me
demandais est-ce que toute révolution
déboucherait sur euh une forme de guerre
civile ? C'était Je pensais que c'était
ça que tu me demandis.
Ouais. Une révolte
hein.
C'est quoi la différence entre une
révolution et une révolte ?
une
c'est bon la révolte disons que la
révolte ne met pas à ou ne met pas à les
institutions. La révolution met à bas
les institutions. Alors pour en
reconstruire d'autres ou c'est c'est
disons comme ça que
félicitation tu es la seule personne en
150 émissions qui été
j'arriver à la définir. Bon ah oui voilà
et donc c'est un c'est la destruction
d'un ordre. La révolution la révolte met
à mal momentanément
un ordre mais ne le met pas à bas. Bon,
enfin, c'est comme ça que moi je je
dirais. Euh
donc
est-ce que il va y avoir enfin est-ce
qu'il va y avoir guerre civile ?
Ça c'est des choses auxquelles
évidemment il est hyper difficile de
répondre, mais enfin l'histoire a
tendance à montrer que
la la les révolutions débougent toujours
sur des guerres civiles et notamment
on a les armées de mercenaires qui sont
envoyées contre les tentatives
révolutionnaires.
Alors ben ça, on les a vu sur toutes les
formes révolutionnaires
au Nicaragua contre les Sandinistes, à
Cuba, à quel qu'elle soit ces
révolutions. Bon, ça ça c'est une chose.
Et donc je croyais quand tu me demandais
ça, j'allais te répondre "Oui, ben
voilà, c'est il risque d'y avoir ça."
Euh après, ça dépend de comment d'où a
lieu cette révolution, comment elle a
lieu, comment elle se répand, comment
est-ce qu'elle se fait par
l'intermédiaire d'une grève générale.
Voilà.
quel est quel est son soutien et cetera.
Bon euh ensuite en revanche sur la
question, ça là aussi il y a déjà eu des
réponses euh en période révolutionnaire
sur des changements de modèle. Euh par
exemple à l'inverse si tu veux, c'est
pendant la commune on a donné la
retraite au aux vieux et aux infirmes,
tu vois, pendant la commune de Paris.
Donc tu vois, tu me dis "Ouais, mais
comment on ferait pour les les vieux et
tout Mais c'est pas le capitalisme qui
donne des retraites, c'est les
travailleurs quand ils se mobilisent
qu'ils obtiennent des retraites. Le
capitalisme, il préférerait pas en
donner. D'ailleurs, il ils vont sans
doute les enlever.
Il y a un actif pour combien de
retraités
hein
en ce moment ? Non mais ça je sais pas
mais si tu veux alors donc donc le les
les ce que si tu me parlais de tout ce
qui été les acquis ou conquis sociaux
euh ils ont été gagnés par euh les les
les gens les travailleurs euh dans des
luttes euh qu'ils ont souvent euh pris
euh à ceux qui possèdent les moyens de
production. Donc s'il y a une révolution
bah c'est pas ça qu'ils vont perdre. Euh
ce qu'ils vont perdre, c'est plutôt
comme disait Marx, leur chaîne. Bon,
dans dans l'autre sens et pour tu as une
un très bon livre euh de
bon sur les bullshit jobs de bon, je
vais plus me rappeler de son nom. Euh
t'inquiète, ça va venir. Il y a 5000
personnes en direct.
David,
tu le regardes David ?
Alors, on on
c'est David. Et bon,
je te pose je te pose euh la question.
Demandez-lui trois livres. Donc
commence. Donc tu as celui-là sur les
bullshit jot.
Mais le le livre
c'est Gbert, non hein ?
Gbert
Grabert.
Ouais. David Graber. [__] David
Graber.
Merci à la communauté.
Euh merci. Euh donc qui montre par
exemple euh et euh chose qui a été
reprise je crois par euh parant euh qui
montre euh que euh
je vais dire un mauvais euh un mauvais
sondage hein, mais que euh 60 % de nos
occupations, de nos travaux sont des
travaux qui ne sont pas productifs.
Voilà. Euh, Azan a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle prre première mesure
révolutionnaire dans lequel il te montre
que au lendemain de la révolution euh
d'une révolution, si elle avait lieu,
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire et
qu'est-ce qui se passerait ? Ben, il te
montre que tu as 30 % des gens seulement
qui font des travaux qui servent qui
nous servent à vivre. Le reste c'est du
marketing, de la comptabilité, euh de
je vais pas je pourrais même mettre de
la production audiovisuelle dedans euh
pour le coup vraiment puisque la
production audiovisuelle quand même
globalement ça consiste à aller discuter
avec des chaînes de télévision, avec des
gens dans les chaînes de télévision et à
faire des dossiers pour lesquels on a
des subventions. Donc ça, il y aura
plus, il y aura pas besoin. Si tu as
envie de faire un film, tu convains des
potes, on arrive à les faire ensemble et
puis on on les diffuse. tu auras plus
toutes ces ces administrations ou
paradministration
qu'il y a bah là pour le coup dans les
chaîne de télévision, dans les
je sais pas moi dans les musées, dans
les
Tu veux te faire des copains là ?
Tu veux te faire des copains ? Non mais
non mais mais c'est pas ça. Mais non
parce que c'est aussi de dire que
ce qui veut dire qu'il y aura il y
aurait plus de temps libre puisque tous
ces travaux ne sont pas des travaux qui
beaucoup de ces travaux-là sont pas des
travaux qui servent à produire ni ni
même le superflux.
C'est du du travail de gestion, de flux,
de choses comme ça, mais qui ne servent
même pas à produire le le du luxe. Je
suis même pas en train de parler de la
production du luxe qui serait n'est pas
touché là-dedans, hein. Aan le raconte
très bien dans ses premières mesures
révolutionnaires.
Je te coupe.
Ouais.
Euh, deux autres livres que tu
conseilles à la communauté.
Mais li à l'anarchisme ou euh
ce que tu
Oh, je sais pas moi non. des des livres,
il y en a il y en a plein. Le Monde
comme volonté, comme représentation de
Chopenhauer, je pense que c'est un des
maisid
évidemment
l'art d'avoir toujours raison de
toujours Arthur Chopenhower.
Ouais. Euh
voilà. Bon après moi je lis énormément
donc j'ai pas de je peux dire un des
livres là dernièrement qui m'a qui m'a
marqué très fortement c'est à bord du
négrier de Red Cerur que j'ai trouvé un
livre
énorme
non seulement dans l'histoire évidemment
qu'il raconte parce que je crois que
c'est euh jamais j'avais été j'avais été
aussi près effectivement de ces voyages
de négrier mais euh mais en plus qui qui
qui fait cette fameuse méthode
d'histoire par le bas et qui et qui
propose comme hypothèse que c'est le
capitalisme n'est là. Et donc ça c'est
c'est vraiment très intéressant. C'est
vraiment très intéressant. Voilà.
Donc tu as déjà regardé nos nos
programmes ? Tuas tu as vu quoi ?
Ah non, je serais je serai foutu de te
le dire parce que là on est trop près
des vacances donc ça remonte et moi j'ai
une très mauvaise mémoire des noms.
C'était quoi le sujet ? C'était quoi le
sujet ? C'était je pense que c'était sur
le logiciel libre. Est-ce que vous vous
avez dû faire quelque chose sur le
logiciel ?
Tu voulais engager quelqu'un qu'on
connaît ? Non.
Tu voulais engager quelqu'un connait ça
? Ouais.
Jérémy.
Ouais. Voilà.
On lui passe le bonjour.
Ouais. On lui passe le bonjour.
Ça s'est pas fait avec Non. Alors le en
fait en fait le le film euh donc c'était
c'est un documentaire, je raconte aux
gens, c'est un documentaire qu'on
spoile pas hein hein.
Non non non mais c'est un documentaire
qu'on devait faire justement sur le
logiciel libre et euh le et donc le
réalisateur,
comment il s'appelle notre pote ?
Euh Jérémy Zimmerman. Non hein, on parle
de lui. Ouais. Euh Jérémy Zorman, donc
ancien de la quadrature du net que je
trouve absolument formidable et et moi
m'a énormément appris dans les moments
qu'on a passé ensemble.
Et en fait, il s'est trouvé que dans le
et donc avec un réalisateur qui
s'appelle Philippe Borel qui est un
réalisateur qui a aussi réalisé un monde
sans humains, euh un monde sans travail
justement aussi sur la la robotisation
et cetera. Et en fait, ils ont eu en
cours de de de film un désaccord sur ce
qui était le cœur du film. Et donc en
fait donc il y a eu séparation et
Philippe a fait un film en réalité
beaucoup plus sur les communs en réalité
qui était en fait le truc qui le
travaillait et il a fait un film sur les
communs et effectivement Jérémy voulait
qu'on reste bien sur la question du
logiciel libre. Voilà,
c'était pas notre question mais merci
d'avoir
mais c'est pour pour raconter mais
c'était c'est pas Jérémy que j'ai vu il
y était Jérémy je l'ai vu. Je
sais pas.
Non mais dans tuas vu chez nous
hein
c'est peut-être Benjamin Bayard. Non
non mais je sais plus je sais plus.
Bon c'était intéressant. C'était très
bien mais je trouve je trouve euh
que je t euh correspond euh comment vous
informez, quel média, quelle télé ?
Euh alors moi je regarde pas la télé,
enfin j'ai pas la télé donc euh je
regarde pas la télé. Euh je lis euh bon
après moi je lis euh ben le monde le
parisien, ça c'est mes deux petites
lectures du matin.
Personne n'est parfait hein.
Euh je lis lundi matin, je lis euh
Marianne
non non. [rires] Je lis je lis euh je
lis des euh je suis aussi pas mal sur
des trucs euh disons des euh enfin là
mais on parle en en site en site web euh
ouais ben je vais sur ben après je je
papillonne je vais sur la
la c'est c'est anarchiste
ou les Ouais antif
les mot sont importants c'est quoi la
différence entre
disons que c'est plus c'est plus euh
c'est plus un regroupement disons que
comme comme comm comme végan c'est ceux
qui sont antif ils sont agressif ou pas
les antifas
euh la horde
ça dépend avec qui mais c'est non c'est
plutôt un travail de d'information qui
qui est fait par la
bon bah
disons bah après il y a l'organisation
de manifestations antifasciste
Mais
l'antifascisme c'est c'est pareil le le
disons le le moment les le coup de point
et tout ça qui finalement est assez
rare. Et il y a eu ce ce grand événement
qui a marqué qui est la rencontre
avec des skinet d'un d'un petit groupe
d'antif dans lequel Clément Mic a été
tué. euh n'est pas euh euh disons euh
n'est n'est pas le le quotidien et moi
je suis pas hyper spécialiste pour
parler de de ce que font les
organisations antifascistes, mais n'est
pas le quotidien euh de l'organisation
antifasciste, c'est pas euh la la traque
au FAF, c'est enfin ou c'est de la
traque au FAF mais qui se fait aussi sur
internet mais c'est c'est de
l'information, c'est de montrer les
réseaux, c'est de montrer la diffusion
des pensées.
Des fois des fois ils se plantent un peu
les reprises.
Ouais mais mais surtout des fois ils
sont la la horde par exemple ils sortent
de de des infos très intéressantes. Là
la dernière avec Yanusas qu'ils ont
sorti, je crois que c'est eux c'est la
proximité de de Colomb avec les
identitaires lyonnais quand même. C'est
très intéressant ça.
Colomb le maire de Colomb. Ouais. Le
donc le maire de Lyon, ministre de
l'intérieur avec les identitaires
lyonnais et notamment le l'un des chef
des identitaires lyonnais. Et c'est
c'est vraiment intéressant. Donc ce qui
permet de de relire ou de mieux un petit
peu comprendre comment Colon minimisait
les expéditions dans les dans les dans
les Alpes pour empêcher les les réfugiés
de passer en disant que c'est euh je
sais plus quoi, que c'était des trucs de
scoutot, enfin je sais plus exactement
ce qu'il avait dit. Euh bon ben voilà,
maintenant quand on sait que il est très
très proche euh de euh de de l'un des de
du fameux chef, je me rappelle plus son
nom maintenant, euh mais en plus il a
deux noms euh enfin bon euh bah c'est
c'est euh on comprend mieux pourquoi il
minimise ça et pourquoi les black c'est
horrible et euh et en revanche ça c'est
euh c'est c'est des petites opérations
scout joyeuses à la campagne quoi. Donc
voilà et euh non je je sais je peux pas
te dire c'est pareil, c'est un peu comme
les livres, je sais pas, je lis plein de
choses, je regarde beaucoup de
documentaires, beaucoup de
Tu sais qu'à la fin de notre de nos
émissions, on demande toujours la même
question
non
qui est laisser, c'est pas une question
en fait hein, c'est laisser un conseil
pour les jeunes générations.
Laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Bah je sais pas moi. Non mais les jeunes
générations elles font ce qu'elles
veulent. Moi, je vais essayer d'avoir
des conseils pour nous quoi, nous
organiser euh et euh et d'essayer de de
faire bloc quoi. Voilà, je pense que les
jeunes générations se se débrouilleront.
Tant cradr monnaie. Merci.
Merci.
[musique]